Hello everybody, hello everyone, I'm so sorry, oh my gosh,
like right before I take a very important work call with
mint, just, uh, um, and I, oh my gosh, so many things was
going on, and I had to do, like, finish some work stuff too,
right after, uh, and so I'm, I'm all over the place, I'm so
sorry, I think I've been waiting, everyone, oh, I'm so
blind, everyone will be like this, everyone's like 30
minutes ahead of me, I'm only Musha now, ah, don't guys, I
see you.
It's launch day!
Yippee!
Sorry, I'm all over the place.
Yeah.
Hello, everyone.
Hello, welcome to launch day for Oni Musha.
Oh, my gosh.
It's been 20 years.
It's been 50 years.
It's been 80 years.
But it's finally here.
Hello, everybody.
Yes, Oni Musha, way of the sword.
Huge shout-out.
And thank you to MSI for sponsoring today's show.
stream.
For those who don't know, we're going to be doing the usual
thing when it comes to MSI sponsoring us.
This is not the first time MSI has sponsored us.
But at the end of stream, I'll be giving away five game
codes.
Don't worry, this time I know how many game codes I'm giving
away.
It's unlike last time where I was like, I'm going to give
away 10.
And then my manager message me is like, Doki, we only have
five.
You sort of miscounted in game five additional game Shit,
this time I know we have five game codes this time for I
counted this time Because last time yeah last time we were
like um it was like don't keep us counted.
Can you give us five more game codes?
This time this time we're we know now So at the end of
stream I'll be giving five game codes what we're gonna do as
always is that we're hosting a little giveaway where you
have to do exclamation point enter to enter the giveaway and
if you get picked um if you get picked you have 24 hours to
DM my manager not dokey merch this time but my manager's
twitter so if you guys didn't know my manager has made a
twitter account finally has made a twitter account you can
even meet my manager at vexbo he's gonna be there um and uh
apparently he's gonna wear I think he's going to wear, I
don't know, I think he got the sample, one of the samples
for it.
I'm not sure, but he might be wearing one of the Gina Draws
varsity jackets, either mine or stuffy.
And so you're going to have to, if you win the giveaway.
Also, the reason why, so like people can't be like, can't
impersonate my manager.
So people will know like, oh, that's silent.
So we decided, like usually in the past, he was a silent
manager.
So he was working behind the scenes.
They have a good time.
This account has been up for a while to have a actual
official manager Twitter account so that he has a social
presence.
So there won't be any misunderstandings regarding who my
manager is.
Someone won't be randomly claiming, I'm Doki's manager.
So that's why we decided.
Because nowadays, I feel like a lot of managers are now
public now, on public Twitters and everything.
They started to have a social presence.
scenes and taking the backstage of a lot of things but we
decided to have a social presence uh on social media uh just
so like there's no like impersonations going on or like
being people being sent like a random email being like i'm
doki's manager would you like to do this and then they dm me
being like hey i got an email from your manager about this
opportunity is this true and i'll be like who the are you
i've been i just said i'd be like who what this is the first
so yeah so i was finally the right time to have a social
media for for my manager
anyway uh and also if you have anything important or like
important that you need a response well guys please don't
spam my manager but if there's any like uh important
questions or like concerns or anything you can dm my manager
since he has You don't, has a social media account now.
So, you, but anyway, if you are picked, if you are picked
and won the giveaway for Onimusha, you have 24 hours to DM
my manager and show proof that you won the giveaway.
And then he will give you the GameCube.
Yeah, GameCube, sorry.
Your very own GameCube.
He will give you a game code.
GameCube.
Sorry, disclaimer, there is no GameCube.
There is, there is, there is no GameCube in this giveaway.
Disclaimer, the GameCube's a lie.
Oh, sweet, a GameCube.
Fuck Oni Musha.
I'm here for the GameCube.
Oh my god.
We don't believe her lies.
It comes with the GameCube too.
Thanks, MSI.
This is in 2005 all over again.
Oh my god, man, that, that, that, what's the word?
That age, that age is you.
There's some dragoons here that was born in 2005.
Anyway.
Anyway, guys, let me, let me make sure I have everything.
But yes, this is my manager.
Discord, sorry, Discord is my manager's Twitter account
Yeah, me This hurts me Wait a minute Someone born after 2000
Let's see Alright, before I start Everything Let me, I need
a BRB real quick Because I realized I need a feed dad Sorry,
I was so busy It always happens Right before stream, too.
Because it was either I get a call with Mint after the
stream or tomorrow.
But then I was just like, I don't know how long I'm playing
Onimusha.
So I don't want to keep Mint up.
So I was just like, no, we can do a call.
Like, I was also in the middle of War Dogs.
So thank God she was like, can we do a call?
Because I was getting absolutely destroyed in War Dogs.
For those who don't know, there's a new game.
Okay, sorry.
Huge shout out to MSI Think again for the sponsor.
Anyways, for those who don't know, there's a new game called
War Dogs.
like okay it's fucking crazy it's so all my friends were on
blue team there was that we're on red team and then me and
ben because like ben was like oh god check it out and and
then yeah i was in the beta uh damn she's talking so fast
guys i can get the story out quick because i'm already 40
minutes behind everybody's already like at the past the
tutorial like it's launched in i'm 40 minutes behind.
Fudge top.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'll say the question on everyone's mind for Sight.
Are you single?
He has a wife.
Thank you for that super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, you guys like, and does he have a husband though?
Like, yeah, but does he have a husband?
You know, morality?
He could have too.
Dalek, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you,
thank you, um, love, thank you for super chat, thank you,
thank you, just because there's a goalie doesn't mean we
can't, oh, that's so true, wait, that's actually, wait, I
love, that's a good line, that's a really good line, has it
ever worked?
Early stream treat for a favorite, welcome to your own
stream, love, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
Doki Satoru Nate has special message for you.
I hope you get to see it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Um, L.
Thank you.
Anyway, fuck.
Okay.
So, because you're telling me to get on, but because it took
me so long to go through the tutorial, um, for this one, I
don't know, Ben, I usually play, I usually do this off
stream, but you might have met them when I did the aisle
stream, but sometimes, um, sure for it, Ben and Gully would
hit me up to play.
Well, I'd be off stream, but they would be playing a friend
slop game.
And then I hop in in their group.
So it's usually like cheer for Golly and Ben or Mr. Cal.
Mr. Cal slash Ben.
That's his name.
It's like the core set.
And then it would be like, I'm like the plus what, like the
special guest appearance.
You know, like the special guest star.
So I'd be like the guest star of the day sometimes when I
hop into their friend slot games.
so it's usually like me rain and mu uh that would be like or
hewn that would be guest starring in their daily friend slop
stuff um so so uh they asked me to hop i was like i only
have two hours till the till the sponsor so they asked me if
uh i wanted to hop in on war dogs so war dogs is uh i still
don't fucking really understand it that much because i only
had like lesson i've only played it for And I had to go on a
call with me.
And so War Dogs is basically like battlefield, but also
rust.
Also sort of rust-like because there's like, you have to
make bases and stuff.
You have to build and everything.
So you can be a builder.
You can be a sniper.
You can be a medic.
You can be the truck driver that goes and delivers supplies
to bases to build more stuff.
You can be the pilot to deliver the people, like you, to
pilot to take people to like destinations.
So there's three teams.
and a hundred, it's a hundred man server and with a hundred
people are divided into three teams.
And you have to take the objective and you gain points and
stuff in the objective.
So everyone has like tasks and stuff.
You can be a helicopter driver, the truck driver, the FedEx
delivery guy, the medic, the builder, the mortar operator.
There's like several roles.
So then I hopped in and then I got a blue team and now I saw
Ben and out Ben I was like where is everyone and then Ben
was like they're all in the red team Dokey it's just you and
me I was like no because I got in late because like I had to
wait because the server was full so I had to wait and I got
in and all our friends are on red team and they're like
we're getting and he was like Dokey they're all on the red
team it's just you and me and I was like no because and red
team was absolutely destroying us so War tore us apart.
We were on opposite sides.
So, so you see, I was the new one.
Because I didn't play the game last beta.
I didn't play the game.
So, it never changes.
So, I didn't play the last beta.
Because this is the second beta that they opened beta that
they did.
And so, I was just like, So they're like Ben was just like
just grab your supplies and I grabbed everything, but a gun
Because I was like Ben what role are you playing?
He was I'm being medic right now And I was like I can be
medic so I got all the med kits and the bandages, but I
forgot the gun I was like I can whatever we'll just be
medics together And I forgot because the whole concept of
this that we each get cash on us you kill the more you help
the base up you earn cash to buy to upgrade your stuff like
video game cash not real money by the way not real video
game cash so we all get like 10k and then you got to make
money to spend money so i i okay anyway so because then you
have to track okay you're transported to like the
battlefield and everyone's shooting us and i was like wait i
have no gun and so and so i was just like i don't know what
i'm doing bed i
okay and then and then so so i was just like struggling i
was getting absolutely destroyed like i finally got a gun by
the way i finally got a gun and i was trying to shoot and i
was like and it was like go to the base and i went to the
base and i got fucking mortared by fucking sure for it like
because he was just shit that's all he was doing he was just
building fucking he was just fortnighting he was just
minecrafting at the base building shit and then sending
mortar rounds out towards us.
And then my first, my fucking first step was being sure for
a set of goddamn mortar on me.
And then I looked at the stream, and then he was like, nuke
down.
And everyone's chat was like, ha ha, nuke down at Tokey
Bird.
And I was like, because I am a noob.
I don't know what's going on.
I, I didn't know what was, I didn't know what was going on.
I was so confused I was literally my first five minutes of
the game it was like the first of the game I'm literally
just a little chud right and then um and and then like Ben
was just trying to like, like, it was like trying his best
to take care of the little baby.
And I was like, Ben, where are you?
I'm like, God!
He's like, I killed a guy, I looted his body for a gun.
And I was like, okay!
Just a little juggling.
And then I was like, Ben, I think I think war's not as fun
as I thought it'd be.
War might not be that fun.
word might not be that fun I and then and then obviously
there was a huge fight on us and I straight up was like and
then my message like hey can we get it like oh yeah can we
do a call real quick blah blah and I was like yeah I was
like oh thank God that's just I could because I'm just like
I was just like oh thank God my get up jail free card I was
like no he's like she's like no it's okay we can do the call
tomorrow after your share like no it's okay it's so it's
five no we can it's okay we can we can get in a car i was
like i was like ben do not res me i'm do not res me i have a
very important work call i he's like okay i was like it was
like ggs i have and i was like after that to do the stream i
the extraction yeah i got extracted from the battlefield i
yeah i was like good luck because then he was all alone he
because at first it was like me ben and dyrus and dyrus um
got off the moment i logged like god like not the moment i
got he's just like oh god it's still cute and left he was
just like the timing was just the fact that after like the
first five minutes he uh got off he was like i'm done for
the day and then so It was just me and Ben.
And Ben was just left all alone now.
This is where we're getting absolutely shit on by our
friends.
Like, no man left behind except for Ben.
Yeah.
Yeah, so I was just like, sorry, I'm getting distracted now.
See you guys.
But it's crazy.
Like, I don't know.
right now I don't know about how I feel about war dogs
because I we were just getting shit on like by like all the
gamers on on red team like I was trying to I was legit
waiting the team swap but they're everyone just stayed on
red team um but I heard that I don't know I heard a lot of
people has have wish lists because you can play any role you
want like it can play like whatever role you want to play in
terms of like you know you could be a builder you can play
Minecraft You can play Fortnite slash Minecraft.
You could be the medic.
You could be the FedEx delivery.
The Amazon delivery guy.
So it was chaotic.
I will say.
It was very chaotic.
Anyway, I'm going to go feed Dad real quick.
And then we'll go straight into Onimusha.
I'll be right back, everybody.
I'll be right back.
All right, I'm back.
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, wait, I already said that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you fanfic for 803 mid as solid snake and saving
private Don't keep bird from hellscape.
Thank you for the super chat.
It literally plays like battlefield But like there's like
voice proximity and like squad squad voice and everything is
like king of the hill I think it's the only game mode they
have was king of the hill It was it I felt like it was a
little bit complicated on how they like How to get the
points and everything but like it's just chaotic.
It's it's like you were in a war if you were like actually
war war never changes yeah you can play it's like
battlefield but you can just be you can just stay in your
base and build mortar build up fucking mortar rounds and
just mortar people all day long yeah alright let me make
sure I just realized I forgot to pin pin the information so
let do that real quick.
Like I said, please shout out again for MSI for sponsoring
the stream and letting me play Onimusha
Let's see.
I'm going to make sure I do the pin message real quick.
But there is a special collaboration right now between MSI
and onimusha so uh we do the onimusha game bundle right here
um let me pin this real quick oh sorry pin this message real
quick uh check out the onimusha game bundle uh
But yeah, but yeah, again, sorry again for being late, guys.
Like I said, everything happened like 30 minutes before the
stream was supposed to start.
Because I had to get into this in the call.
And then after that, like, it was like something important I
had to do.
And then so then I really apologize.
But thank you guys again for coming to the stream.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you again to MSI for us always versus the support.
So that out for the support.
And for...
And for sponsoring today's stream.
Alright, let me make sure we got all the information set up
before we play.
I'm really looking forward to playing Onimusha.
Just because, like, it's a game series I grew up with.
Like I said, when I was little, I would watch my dad play
the first Onimusha.
First two Onimusha games.
Maybe three.
I don't remember three very well.
The first two.
Oh, the director has a message for me.
Wait, does he actually...
Oh my god!
Where is it?
Hey Andy!
Andy must have done- I was confused!
I didn't realize you met on Twitter!
Wait, what the fuck?
Okay, and then there wasn't Andy like-
Oh, he watched you play Ouija 2 as well.
Oh, my God.
There's no...
There's what?
I didn't understand it, to be fair.
Guys, I was just in the war an hour ago.
That's so cool!
That's so, that's actually so fucking cool.
Oh my god.
Okay, but you guys said you had a special message for me, so
I thought like you meant like maybe there's a message in
game.
I didn't realize you meant like, no I'm trying.
Okay, guys, guys, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
I'm quote-unquote retweeting it.
I'm quote-unquote retweeting it right now.
I, bro, what?
I don't know what to say, but thank you so much.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe it.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's crazy.
I...
What?
No.
What's even right?
It's a tweet.
I just wrote, what...
Bro, I don't know what to say.
But thank you so much.
I'm putting the shout out.
Little Doki would be so happy.
But...
Present.
President Duke would have never expected this
oh I was not that wow I'm gonna message Andy real quick I
I'm gonna I'm gonna be like at Andy did you was that you did
you organize this I messaged Andy oh my god yeah and he's
like oh I don't I don't do
yeah that's insane oh my god that's crazy
Oh my god This is Oh my god I started stream too Watch him
say no Okay wait but like He's not even online Who did this?
No it has Okay it might not be added could be someone else
in the management team It could also be It could also be
like someone else from the management team Yeah Yeah
oh my god it could be like any it could be any of them it
could i'm sorry i'm sorry no i should be playing i'm just so
speechless right now i i was not expecting this and then
they fucking lord dropped me and being like i we know you
played watch your dad play this growing up and everything
too and i was like oh my god this is especially tailored for
me too
This is... This is tailored to me.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
I need to breathe.
I...
That is just...
It was... It's a very nice detail.
It's just...
A very nice detail.
Twasai!
I do it!
it yes oh my god thank you did i really naturally made my
day i was not expecting it at all yeah bro shout out to andy
the goat oh my god wow i'm sorry i'm so giggling right now I
just cannot believe it a real man real one he's a real one
real man he's a fucking homie holy shit what a fucking bro
right now oh I'm sorry I'm super I'm super giggly right now.
I just, I, I did, okay, when you guys are like, he has a
message for you, I just assume he wrote, like, a special
forward, like, in the game or something, like, there's,
like, a special message, and, like, I didn't, like, like,
towards everybody.
I didn't realize, you met, like, on Twitter!
He's made a specific, like, a video specifically directed
towards me.
I, that's crazy.
I didn't know.
It was a great surprise.
It was actually...
I think...
Oh my god.
It was...
I think it's also because like...
I was like one of a few VTubers that I've played.
Like I guess like bigger VTubers that I've played this game
as well.
When the remaster was released as well as like the original.
I don't know.
I just have very fond memories of Onimusha.
It's very campy.
And I really...
I have like very fond memories of like watching my dad play
the game and everything too.
So it was a very...
special place in my heart onimusha i always begged my dad to
play more of the games too whenever a new onimusha game i
remember when odomusha 3 came out i was like begging my dad
to play it for me because i i was too scared to play it
because i was like i was so young i was so scared of playing
myself because i was just a little bird so i would beg my
dad to play same with resident evil 4 i would beg my dad to
play resident evil 4 and onimusha for me so i can watch him
play and uh and it it holds a very special place in my heart
so i was very hyped when i found out a new old motion game
was coming out and everything and um oh my god it is oh my
gosh i'm so i can't believe the director gave me a shout out
yeah yeah oh i can't believe it wow that's that's wild that
is that's actually wild lala you think it was super chat
thank you thank you our oh she keeps winning dragons thank
you they also sent me a pr package too um so maybe i'll open
it later on just to tell you guys what's in it uh because i
didn't have time to open it yet so they did send me a pr
package for owning mooshah i'm super excited to open it
later on um um but yeah anyway fuck sorry back to msi thank
you msi thank you again msi let me finish posting the tweet
about uh the msi promotion
real quick for you guys oh I'm sorry I'm so I'm so giggly
right now oh my god just got back got out of war an hour ago
I got extracted out of war and I had to go into a work call
and I got fucking dropped back in be like good luck dokey
the roller coaster oh my god the the roller coaster of
emotions right now.
I literally I'm still, I literally just came back from the
battlefield to all of this so I'm, give me a sec.
I need to like calm down a little bit and finish typing, um,
finish setting up the, uh, setting up the stuff for the
sponsor.
Ah, I'm sorry, I'm just, oh, my mind is like right now.
Yeah, he launched his own mortar.
Oh, sorry, I'm like, oh.
Okay, all right, let's see, let me, gotta get that, let me
pin, I'm sorry, I still need to pin the message.
I still need, I still need to pin the message.
All right.
Professional bird here.
Oh, my God.
I accidentally pinned Onimusha.
I know.
I accidentally.
Oh, I'm so clumsy right now.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm so, I'm so clumsy at the moment.
I accidentally pinned the Onimusha director tweet back.
The, wow.
Okay.
All right.
giving away we're giving also giving away game codes and a
stream oh all right here we go all right yeah i'm blushing
guys i'm just full of emotion right now like a lot of things
guys war lots of things happen things happen.
All right.
Let me make sure everything else is fully set up so we can
get started.
All
right.
So for those who don't know about the promotion,
check out the bundle.
Oh my gosh, give me a sorry.
Sorry.
It's just a word message regarding.
All right.
So there is a promotion going on regarding Onimusha.
Sorry, my brain is like short circuiting right now.
Like, so
you purchase any of the MSI monitors or you already own one
of the MSI monitors in this promotion.
um feel uh by clicking on the link on Doki Bear Onimusha or
Doki Bear recommended you can have a free copy of Onimusha
that you can claim and I'm also giving away game codes at
the end of the stream so if you stick around by the at the
end of the stream I'll be giving away away five game codes
um and also to check out oh say oh my god I did it my hands
are shaking I'm sorry my hands are shaking I just realized
my spelling mistakes right now.
Oh, I'm like all over the place.
Oh, I felt like I got jump scared today.
I there was so many there was actually today a lot of stuff
happened today.
So like this one this like pushed me over the edge.
It pushed me out of off.
It pushed me over the So yeah, by purchasing a selected MSI
monitor and posting a review, you can redeem and claim your
very own Onimusha PC game code.
So if you click on the link, the Adobe keyboard, Onimusha,
and if you've already purchased an MSI product before and
purchased an MSI selected monitor, you can get another extra
stream wallet up to $100 US dollars.
Wow!
So yeah, just click on...
click on the links and everything and you should be good to
go so again huge shout out to MSI for always sponsoring me
and uh sponsoring me and like I said I use the MSI monitors
I have the uh I have the I'm pretty sure I have my current
model is the MSI uh one of the MSI models that as in the
recommended that's why I recommended them and I have a 500
hertz monitor um that definitely did It definitely did in...
Oh my god, I...
I'm going through a lot of emotions right now.
All right, I'm sorry.
Here you go.
Third time's the charm.
Third time's the charm, guys.
Thank you again for always sponsoring me.
Today's a very emotional day.
Today's...
today has been a very emotional day but it really does mean
a lot if you check out the monitors like i said you can also
have the monitor the same monitor as me i use one uh i use
uh one of the msi monitors uh and um it did increase my
performances when it comes to like competitive shooters um
and uh because i do use a 500 hertz monitor so obviously for
me frames does matter a lot and it does support me if you
guys purchase an msi monitor or uh the ones that i recommend
looking for a new monitor.
This is a big upgrade in general in terms of gaming and
everything.
And you also get free copy of Onimusha.
Is that great?
You also get a free copy of Onimusha.
But huge shout out again to MSI for sponsoring.
Like I said, that was helpful a lot.
You click on the link and purchase your own MSI monitor via
the link.
It does help out the stream, help out MSI, and helps out the
shadow.
So huge shout out to them.
Please check them out.
Anyway.
Oh, all right.
Let's get started.
Wait, let me double check this information real quick.
Whoopsie.
All right, let's boot it up.
All right, we're playing for real.
I'm a bit...
Oh, I should get my controller.
This is a controller game.
I remember when I played it at...
In New York.
This was 100% a controller game.
I gotta make sure...
Oh, sorry.
I'm like all over...
My mind is just racing.
There was a lot of stuff going on today, so I'm like, oh my
gosh.
Well...
Everything's going on today.
Let's see.
Oh, I'm compiling shaders.
Well, what a day.
What a day.
Professional streamer here.
I'm an hour behind everybody on launch.
day but there's so many things was happening today let's
see oh we're waiting for everything to get set up i don't
think our timer's on yet let me tell my manager about this
real quick
oh good morning jk thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you finally we're getting more ancient warlock oh
that's thinking of a super chat thank you Uh, Papa, thank
you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is the closest I've been to seeing someone recover from
concussion grenade live.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
I don't know what you're talking about.
There's no, there's no game queue.
There's only, there's only a game code.
Um, oh my god, it takes so long to compile.
Uh, the thing.
Here we go.
It.
Alright.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
Wait.
This controller has no...
Oh!
Wait.
This is a bad controller.
I have my controller again.
Give me...
Ah!
This controller has no symbols on it.
It's because it's as...
Oh my gosh, okay, oh my gosh, oh, oh my brain, I'm so
scattered.
Oh, I was in a war an hour ago, guys.
I, guys, you don't understand.
I was in a war.
I was literally in the battlefield an hour.
I need symbols.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna grab symbols.
I'm gonna grab, I got sent back my controller, guys.
Oh my gosh.
I haven't seen my controller in so long.
I forgot my own controller doesn't have symbols
I forgot my own controller didn't even have symbols I
haven't seen it in months.
I thought it did.
I don't have controller.
I don't remember where an A, B, and C.
Okay, so A, B, X, and O is.
I don't know.
I don't work for me.
I did.
It's been 84 years.
Okay.
A is the bottom.
A.
Okay.
Let's see.
It should be barely visible.
I'll get two.
Okay.
It's barely.
And this.
Until the picture on the left is barely.
visible all right well I hope good luck to me good luck a is
bottom that's all I know I just know a is bottom that's all
I need a note what nice
It doesn't affect...
Okay.
Doki's Eternal War with Snuffy and Bomber Change and Doki
was scared after that brutal war.
Please understand, Cindy.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I know where he is.
All right.
I used mouse and keyboard.
I never...
I didn't grow up with controller games.
I did, actually.
But it's been 84 years.
All right, show subtitle, color.
I feel like I will do white.
Um, maybe large because I'm blind.
Actually, we'll do a medium.
Okay, show speakers color.
Oh, yeah, sound guy.
If you're here, we need your help.
All right, HUD size.
All right, uh, control language.
Blit.
Everything looks good.
You know, fuck it.
Let's go with Ultra.
I should start closing my tabs, though.
I should really close my tabs.
Okay, off.
Oh, that's good.
I'm glad that people have started making motion blur off by
default.
Thank God.
That was my biggest grape.
All right.
Voice will put it high.
Just because, like, it's always voices.
It's always voices that's, like, not balanced, right?
All right.
we begin let us close uh our tabs just as a precaution
oh my god let me close my tabs because i don't i put it in
ultra right now i put it oh my gosh i'm looking at the tweet
again i'm i'm looking at the tweet again whoa
Uh...
Let's see...
I'm closing all my tabs.
Uh...
Is this game available on the GameCube?
Thank you for the super chat, Quill.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, it's not available on the...
I hate to give you...
I hate to be the bearer of bad news, guys.
But...
The GameCube was discontinued.
Since when?
Like 20 plus years ago.
Like, no, Doki, you're lying.
It hasn't been 20 plus years.
Guys, guys.
The GameCube has been discontinued for 20 plus years.
I hate to.
I hate, I hate to.
She lies.
It's only been five years ago.
Don't listen to her.
2005 was only five years ago
someone's like in fact it was 30 years that can't that can't
be true i'm gonna age all of you right now it might have
been 30 years ago since since the GameCube has been
discontinued.
Is this available on the...
Oh, yeah.
Red Tusk, thank you for listening.
For chat, thank you, thank you.
I put...
No, no.
That can't be.
Like, yesterday was 2005.
No.
Also, I said something about the wallet.
By the way, sorry, not the wallet.
There's no wallet promotion this time around.
I misunderstood the promotion.
just because I got the last one.
The last one had it.
So the current promotion is the Onimusha game code.
There's no Steam wallet this time.
This is my bad.
It was just a little misunderstanding.
My mind is a little scrambled with everything going on.
So that's not me.
But again, thank you MSI for the sponsor and for always
supporting me.
Okay.
My managers were like, how are you struggling?
I'm like, please be nice to me.
I'm like, I'm going through a lot right now.
Please be nice to me.
I'm blood moon.
There we go.
That's my excuse.
Be kind to me.
Red dust.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Thank you.
That's also my blood moon.
I just came back from the war.
The moon is shining.
I got out of a work.
I got out of a work call.
I pull the blood moon card.
I'm waiting back from a war to go to another war.
I...
Please.
All right.
Forgive me.
She doesn't know what the fuck she's doing.
Better thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Please be kind to me.
All right.
We like to let you focus on recommended for action.
I'm a beginner.
Action probably.
For experience.
Keep you on the toes.
All right.
I feel like I should play that controller.
Oh, fuck.
It's okay.
What do you mean?
Defensive or aggressive layout?
Focus on responses where more action says either...
Uh, or control so that it's either play defensively.
I mean, I'm always, the best defense is, is offense.
How is it different?
One hand attack, two hand attack, block, parry.
Evade.
Oh, I guess with the evade.
And how the fuck do I examine?
Oh, it's LB.
Oh, block is, okay, what would be easier?
Parrying on X or parrying?
I feel like LB pairing would be easier.
Oh, that's why it's defensive.
for wars.
I I was I was rem I came back from the also did not help.
I went from deadlock to war dogs to work call with Mitt and
then straight to Onimusha like it was back to back war I got
I might have got destroyed
in all the games I played but not this one this would be
different.
This one will be different.
Tom, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It was a very long day.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, watch out.
Last time she used the phrase, but when she had each mod
execute a random trick on during Elden Ring, thank you for
the super chat.
Lolly, thank you.
Thank you.
I see how they go to the super chat.
Just a little child learning came back from the world.
Please be patient i feel like the difference is the
difference here is literally block perry and then okay b for
evade or a for evade a for evade i feel like perry would be
good though that's the if i don't block that's the thing i
don't block so maybe I don't That's the thing though I don't
block So it doesn't really matter Is it I'm here Yeah
Okay X Oh Don't keep Doesn't play defense Oh yeah Blocky is
for cowards Time will tell Oh, I don't know my playstyle.
Oh.
Okay.
Parry or absorb souls.
Uh.
All right, we'll try defense.
Oh, my God.
Oh, the offense is the best defense, though.
Oh, goddammit.
I like A as evade.
I like that evade as A.
Or evade.
Oh.
I would start aggro.
We'll start aggro and see how we feel.
All right, we'll start aggro.
I actually don't know.
It's like, it's so hard.
It's so hard to choose.
It is that deep.
It is.
It's like, it decides.
It decides my whole journey.
It changes everything.
I love the music already.
The music is amazing.
There's...
Is he British?
Sorry, it's just the...
Oh, feed the dog!
Fuck the kids!
Feed the dog!
See, oh, now he wants...
See, look at that!
He wants to feed...
Look at that!
Always the dog!
He was like...
What?
And I was like, that's very British of him.
You what, mate?
For those born...
Wait, he is British!
There is no path.
A steep path crowded with warriors.
I do it!
I heard...
What?
And I was like...
The way forward is through them.
I knew it.
One word.
Miyamoto Musashi, I take it.
I called it.
To challenge me, of all people, what were you thinking?
The Yoshioka school is famous enough, and you're its head.
I was thinking you'd make do for a warm-up you walk in here
my British samurai for that I'll kill you and your entire
family well he just went abroad for a semester guys what can
I say I like to travel light oh my god He just hid back from
my bride.
In that case, I'll send you to hell here and now.
Let's see how that goes for you.
All right.
There's no backing down.
Let's see.
Lock on.
Use some move.
Is my controller?
Excuse me.
Where is...
Oh, no, no.
All right.
There you go.
locked on.
I'm advancing on him.
I'm coming over.
This has to be why, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
That's why.
Fitting for a common banter.
All right.
Stop yammering and fight me.
Okay.
Two.
That is the two-handed ones.
Okay.
All right.
The two-handed attack.
Whoops.
He's moving is cheating
What Okay, okay, okay, die
Okay, man, hit me you're out of breath Yoshioka.
There you go All right, we're doing it.
We're doing it.
He's dodging all my attacks What do I do?
You're just the first step of my path.
That's right.
All in!
Wow!
Where's my debate?
Oh my god, am I?
Can I not evade?
I'm pressing A!
What do you mean?
I rely on evading.
Okay, well, stand body cannot break it.
Attack it, Assyrian Vade.
Their body will turn red and crack depleted.
Cover up time, so keep your...
Okay, wait.
No stamina.
I see that.
That must be the stamina.
Alright.
Give a clue to sign your opponent want to exploit.
You're done, Yoshio Kasejura.
That's right.
Now you have to retire.
You won't hold a sword again with that wound.
This jewel is mine.
I'm being aggressive.
Petrels.
Musashi!
Hmm?
Our school is invincible.
I literally just killed one of your students.
But we can't have our money.
Yeah, I was gonna say invincible title card.
When I can't start sucking.
It's only going to look worse if all of you can't kill me.
Oh, let's see your best then.
I'm sucking the souls.
It's the main Onimusha mechanic.
Venon, you disgraced the way of the sword.
Swordplay is a game of strength.
Winning is what matters.
So true.
And you can bring as many friends as you want.
That's what the British taught me too.
The British Armada.
From my favorite quote.
From Queen Victoria.
King Charles.
He's like, what I learned from a bride.
Big samurai strategy, guys.
Running away tactically.
It's called a tactical retreat.
Yes, a real family model.
I love the graphics, though.
I'm so riled up.
I'm sorry.
What got them so riled up?
I told you, don't come back here without that Musashi's
head.
I feel like I'm in London right now.
London, Japan.
I haven't got any more.
Get out of it.
More treats?
Do I get a... have a die?
What is this chat doing?
You got a license with that sword, mate.
Die!
10 out of 10.
Music down by 10?
Okay, give me a sec.
Right after this cutscene.
okay parry just before an attack prex x just before an
attack uh will land will trigger a parry parrying weapons
base will open up a window oh i okay i don't know the timing
for this all right i i can't tell
okay give me a sec let me oh there's photo mode nice
10.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Which one's A?
This is A.
No.
Did I do it?
Yeah, I did it.
I'm ready.
That's not the parry.
All right, try again.
There we go.
Yeah.
All right, next up.
Okay, not yet.
Try again.
Yeah.
Okay, and then, oh, now I can dodge.
Oh, before being hit.
What?
An unarmed with counter to reduce there.
Okay.
So it's only before.
Okay, it's literally only before.
What the fuck?
He kicked me!
I'm trying to learn!
Oh, alright.
Okay, so that's literally a block.
Okay, why do that when I can block, though?
I feel like blocking would be, parrying would be easier.
Would you let it go already?
Yeah.
Okay, I actually think, legitimately, I don't think
aggressive is right.
Um, X, Y, Yeah, I think I have I don't it doesn't even seem
like an aggressive It doesn't feel like an aggressive
playstyle, you know It's like it's not really it says
aggressive but like The defensive layout feels more
aggression Alright Let's see, alright, do your thing Do your
thing, come on, I'm waiting Wait, I actually already forgot
the control now that we swapped uh give me all right x y
okay x is attack invade okay x y okay there you go okay just
press b just before grab lands cannot be blocked how are you
can form a grab reversal oh gosh probably the ending will
glow blue before they attempt to grab okay all right try
this who's doing it though
mind okay round two all right there you go you ran over your
head all right oh I can't hold it it's also timed I have to
time it and everything everything
is timed what do you mean okay trials why do you mean I
can't just hold it
Oh, boys to 100 didn't get saved?
Oh, oh, I can pause it.
Okay.
I didn't realize it didn't get saved.
I do 95.
Just because they get saved.
Nice.
Let me just so I can look at this again.
The cutscenes are already pretty campy, which I like.
I think the thing I like about the game is that it's so
campy.
It's like, it likes to have fun with it, you know?
It likes to just play around.
It's
something too seriously, which I like.
That's the best part.
Yeah.
I'm getting sick of this.
All right.
Give it up.
All right, we figured it out.
You guys just won't let this go, huh?
Well, I'm game if you want.
Okay.
That's right!
X for days!
Use objects and press A.
So your object can be interacted with during battle by
pressing A.
Oh, like what?
That's right.
I'm the coward.
Oh, that's right.
What you gotta do now?
Boom!
Oh!
That's right!
Chain!
Get chain!
Oh shit, wait, that was pretty cool.
I did a chain attack there.
There's, I think that was something they were supposed to
teach me this later, but I learned that now.
Yota really knows how to welcome a guy.
Five minutes here.
And I covered in blood and flesh.
That's right.
Get out of here!
Alright.
They're all dead now.
Bring sound effects down?
Alright.
I just killed them so I can do that now.
Bring sound effects down by... 10.
There you go.
God, this is so easy.
Who would have known?
Humans are so easy.
to kill him just think there's no other there's no other
enemies other than other humans thank god oh you're not
having kids anytime soon it must feel like a jack of time
will be real
I was like, I've been pointing instantly when he was like,
what?
What?
I was like, wait a minute.
British?
From one word alone.
Hey, Musashi.
Not now.
Oh, this guy.
Okay, this was the guy from the...
He's...
Spoiler!
This...
He may or may not be evil.
I beat that leader.
To be fair, he does sound.
He may or may not be evil.
He was in the demo.
They'll make up any story they like.
You should know that, oh great warrior.
I do know...
Sounds like a...
A chat.
Is it called a chat?
Like...
Oh.
I'm talking about you.
Yeah, he's in the demo.
He's John Demo.
Sasaki.
I don't recall ever losing to you.
Streamer, Canadian, Samurai, Japanese Saxon, British Hota,
and Trivago.
Thank you for the super chat.
He's here.
Thank you.
But there's only room for one at the top.
And it won't be a coward who runs from jewels.
Only one such as...
Oh!
Oh, wait a minute.
I thought this was the one third party.
Oh, well, I guess not now.
He was our nemesis.
I guess he wasn't so evil.
Third party.
No, my father lied.
He didn't proc shield.
Why didn't you use your shield item?
Get off me.
Maybe he's still alive.
Just because he got...
Guys, we didn't see the body yet.
Oh!
Oh, shit!
what and then we we find out he actually was not the main
character wait i died
oh am i not the main character am i wait a minute just the
flesh wound yeah it was a decoy protagonist anyway here's
the guy you're actually playing
Oh, I'm in like the Sea of Souls.
Yeah, when I find out I'm the side character.
Yeah, the River of the Dead.
And then I play his twin brother, who also just came back
from abroad.
Dead.
Oh, yes.
To be specific, you were just on your way to hell when I
pulled you up for a chat.
Hell?
What?
What do you mean?
I did so many good things.
Oh, just because I murdered one guy.
I have to go to hell.
Just one tiny murder.
And I was thinking of a super champ.
Thank you.
Name all the good things you... I fed a dog.
The dog was so hungry.
It's much too soon for you to be heading through Hell's
Moor.
So, this gauntlet is for you.
You pop this on, you get the power of the Oni, and you'll be
back topside.
The Oni.
Just like the legends.
I get the sock.
Q Undertale Music.
How's someone else's?
I walk the...
Pause frame, undertale music.
Suck.
I don't need some monsters' power.
Oh, shit!
When someone gives you a gift, you take it and say thank
you.
I said I don't want it!
You said that could sit!
Oh, don't make that face.
Oh.
I think you'll find that we see I...
to I.
Whoa!
No means no!
I'm just like, I don't wanna suck!
Oni Musha, way of the sword.
He's like, but I don't wanna.
Ah, what's this?
What the fuck?
What?
Yes!
Free food!
I'm just missing a little bit of meat on the shoulder.
Like, there's a giant bite mark on my shoulder.
Are they eating it?
I'll say demons aren't serious.
I do like the original designs of the demons more.
Unimusha 1.
The red, the red and black was so iconic for me.
There's just some chunks missing on my body.
Don't worry, meat grows back, right?
Guys, love the demon designs.
Oh my gosh, the fight scenes are so cool.
I love the demon designs and Unimusha 1.
into the power of the ony they were like such a classic for
me yeah me grows back holy aura this is wrong i didn't ask
for this power
okay press x or y just before being hit you can dodge attack
and hit back oh what oh everything is Oh, it requires even
more precise timing.
Oh, shit!
What's happening to me?
Oh, whoops.
Wait, give me a sec.
Oh, never mind.
Okay, how do I suck?
I forgot to suck.
Oh, the phone!
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, teach me the suck mechanic.
Oh, absorb.
Okay.
Your souls are sometimes left behind.
Absorb them to restore.
Okay.
Wait.
LT?
I just...
Okay.
Yummy, yummy.
Yummy.
All right.
Your turn!
That's right.
Yeah, you saw it happening to you.
Yeah, your turn!
With the power of X!
Oh my god, X my old friend!
old friend l1 has now r1 has become x what is she gonna do
again oh x excellent oh i'm so full oh wait it did grow back
i told you meat grows back guys i knew it see it does see
it's like unlimited food glitch If you're starving In a
deserted island Just cut pieces of meat of yourself It'll
grow back
Oh shit What the fuck?
Who's that?
Who's that, Susie?
God But And that's the use of the chat Thank you, thank you
Oh, Musashi I don't want this filthy power Bro, you can't
pull back me Oh, is it not?
filthy in the slightest but make haste to rokudo chin noji
temple find the man named and it's thinking of the super
chat thank you thank you oh my gosh wife oh now i want it go
now but you girl my steak is just too buttery the hell was
that that I know I have a waifu in it.
Look at that.
See, I have no problem.
Now I have no problem.
It's your AI waifu in ancient Japan.
Love.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They're putting AI in everything now.
What's next?
A data sender in Fudo Japan.
Oh, shit, little girl.
It's not the same as my waifu, though.
Oh, my god.
Wow.
Who's Takamara?
Oh.
Is that Takamara?
Wait, I'm not special?
Why does he have it?
Does she also have a waifu on his arm?
I thought I was the only one.
That's actually new.
In the other Onimusha games, it's always just the one
person.
You're Takamura, right?
Yeah, you see, he's pretty cool.
I can't let I have business with you Do you know Wait, where
did you get?
Whoa Hey, put me down
Rose just aura fire me What are you doing, old man?
Sort out the rest of those bastards We'll see who you've got
business with Once you're done Oh, he's testing me as an
omni Oh, he's testing me user he's like are you worthy for
your waifu he wants to know am i worthy i'll show him check
this combo out they'll never expect it x x x what was she
gonna do next x x that's right and now another x The job's
not done until that Rift is sealed.
Oh, shit.
How do I close this?
Yes.
Where the malice has torn a hole in our world.
Once you're done killing the Gengma bastards that come out
of it.
Absorb it to your corpses.
Okay, I just gotta absorb it.
Oh my god, what is she gonna- What move is she gonna do
next?
Oh my gosh, wait.
Could it be?
X?
Okay.
Get inside.
RT near rift after dense miles will cost rifts.
Okay.
Alright.
Get inside me.
Don't worry, my wife.
Are you hungry?
I'll feed you a five-course meal.
Have you tried?
Why?
Now, guys, guys.
It feels like you're not serious about this game.
Guys.
Alright, bring down okay bring down guys i feel like what do
you mean why a combo doesn't start or end with why all right
another 10 and then voices to 100 all right
i feel like you're not taking this game seriously long story
short you died you came back to life but now you have an ony
gauntlet you've had a busy day Yeah, good.
Thank you.
Come here.
I haven't heard a peep from her since.
Hmm.
She's sleeping, I'd say.
Wait, how do you know about my wife?
After all, that gauntlet is the only thing keeping you from
falling into a heap of tribe.
It's probably taking all she's got to power it.
Hold it.
Then, if I take this off...
You'll die.
Pile of steaks, mincemeat.
being eaten alive.
I guess it's the same for you.
I guess like the trial runs out after he takes it off.
I'm still alive and well when I got mine.
I'm having fun!
I like that it's like sort of campy.
It doesn't take itself too seriously, which I loved about
the Onimusha series.
...
Feeding enough of those and the last in there should wake
up.
That's why I really liked about the series.
Did I really have to come all the way here just to hear
that?
Hmm.
Come.
All right.
I'll show you something that's worth the trip.
I'm glad, like, more people are starting to know about
Onimusha because I felt like it was such a...
It was, like, a bit of a niche game for the first three
games.
Like, the original series.
Not a lot of people talk about Onimusha.
Like, everyone would talk about all the other Capcom games,
but I felt like Onimusha was, like, a game not a lot of
people really talked about.
In general.
It's a well.
Not just any well.
It's very...
Whoa!
What the fuck?
What just happened?
I'm sorry, time he's like, what?
What?
Whenever he gets extra British, it's just...
I'm sorry, I really like the voice acting.
You what, mate?
Watson.
On your feet, Miyamoto-Musashi.
extra british going on what is this place guys he came back
from a semester abroad Kyoto itself is at risk of being
wiped off the map I thought you'd understand your situation
a little faster if you saw the reality while I explain the
gateway to hell is just that's very convenient oh I love the
artwork around it it's not as dangerous as it sounds What do
you mean?
Wait, him?
Takamura?
What are you?
Yeah.
Title drop.
Wait, did I get mine illegally?
Wait, how old are you?
700.
How long have you been an Onimusha?
Say it.
Come on, say it.
And every day I kill them.
Good, honest work.
Why would you agree to that?
Do I have an unregistered godlet?
Why else?
If you live by the sword, fighting is everything.
Or, to put it simply, because it's fun.
How long have you been 700?
I like this guy, too.
He's going to die, isn't he?
He's going to...
Every time.
You're like, they make you fall in love with a character.
And you're like, he's going to die, isn't he?
He's going to fucking die at one point in the story.
Don't, don't.
They're going to kill him off.
He's too good.
cool yes for now they can only trickle into our world
through ridges but if they break through here it'll be more
like a flood and then i have to take over his job oh my god
i can see it now i see the story being written he dies and
then i become the next onimusha Kyoto has powerful shrines
and temples known as key sanctuaries their combined power is
what usually keeps this gate safe however kiosos covered in
malice the meaning the key sanctuaries are as well and the
gate's in trouble correct the sanctuaries have priority but
all of the affected areas need to be purified as soon as
possible okay purify all it really means is killing genma
and closing ribs we need to retire the only way to retire is
through load of genma souls waiting for anyone who might be
up to the task i see where this is going i thought you would
i'd do it myself but then who's to protect the gate from the
outside so i'd go in to hell that's where you come in
serendipity purify the key sanctuaries you get enough souls
to awaken that corner and then my wife Not a bad deal for
either of us.
I don't exactly have any other plans.
So, where do I go?
Come.
Let's head back to the temple first.
Okay.
Alright, thank God.
We don't have to do it now.
He's giving me time to prep, guys.
He's giving me time to set it up.
Oh, outside the magic wheel.
the well i rode in on where am i where did i tp do all right
but what about the child kiyomizudera temple's been attacked
it's completely overrun we've got a hurry
that has to be the fast travel the the wells i have no idea
where that is you might have introduced fast travel that
Okuni, could you show him how to use the spirit mirror?
Oh, wait, never mind.
That's the fast travel.
Ugh.
Come on.
It's right outside.
Oh, and give him a hosuke pouch.
A hosuke pouch?
Is that my...
Yes?
Midni, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, I can sprint.
Bye.
Everything...
Oh.
Oh, it's this.
This made upgrades.
Oh, the shrine's the upgrades.
You don't look like you can feel Takamura's shoes to me.
I wonder they have the similar weapon swap.
Brat, I'm Isamonoa Kuni.
What have you been doing in Kyoto that you haven't heard of
me?
Dying.
And I...
Coming back to life.
It's been a busy trip.
I was in a war.
Several wars.
Anyway, this thing here is a spirit mirror made by the Oni.
station.
Oh, it's the fast travel.
Well, in the past, these were the upgrade stations.
It's a whole sticky pouch.
Oh, is that supposed to know?
They changed it.
Okay.
Okay, oh, so there's my heels.
Alright.
So I have a heels now.
Uh, I replenish from your...
Okay.
Oh, no.
No, okay.
So, unlocking, progressing, by progressing, exploring,
streaming while you fast travel between them.
Making contact will restore your health completely.
Oh, I can change the difficulty.
That's nice of them.
Alright, let's do that.
It opens later?
Okay.
Yeah, that's different.
In the past, because, like, in the old Onimusha games, it
was very, it was, like, very Resident Evil-like, so I can,
like, heal in my inventory.
What's storehouse?
Oh, I don't have anything, so it doesn't really matter.
I guess it's my quick swap.
I don't have anything, so it doesn't matter.
That's my additional content.
I don't have anything in here.
No.
Because there's no DLC.
I guess, I mean, obviously there's no DLC.
It just showed up.
Wait, I'm here, so I have to go here.
Is it here?
Yeah.
definitely is more souls like now because in the past um i
don't know about weapon swaps we're going to see about
weapon swap but the thing about uh me thinking about 10
gifted shits thinking that made only musha very unique is
that i can weapon swap and abuse the different special
abilities for each weapon that really wasn't so i don't know
if this also has it in the demo i was just using the sword
all right let's purify fire this place and see if that won't
wake up golem lady all right oh and spirit mirrored how do i
all right whoops not me to press that hope i'm not missing
any items what what was that i guess i was just running
against this because i don't know how to jump apparently uh
they didn't teach that in samurai school just the bastards
i'm looking for are they eating birds what's better than
humans wait did he who's that oh never mind bird and human
watch this x x x and then x there we go absorbing will make
various oh there we go there are left behind and finishing
enemy would break would make even more.
Alright, so these are my upgrade points.
Yeah, I was going to say where my upgrade points are.
Here's your... I know there's like hidden items in this
game.
I'm paranoid, because in the original Onimusha game, there
were hidden stuff that I could get.
Hey, guys.
Here we go.
Lock.
What's that?
They're like, please use other attacks!
wait suck okay there we go oh shit oh black unless hey okay
with the monsters let me through it threw me off the game
told me to use wine I wasn't used to it right I open up I
was like, what's that?
Hello.
Oh, they're very much alive.
If those things had broken through this horrible...
Oh, whoops.
The temple grounds are just a killing field full of
monsters.
How can this happen?
This is a temple.
It's blasphemy.
I know, right?
How could these demons come into a temple?
Of all things.
If the inside must be a man.
How could dare they?
Hello?
He's going to haunt my nightmares.
I can't stop thinking about it.
Oh my god.
I know.
Have they like...
No mores?
These demons.
As we all know, that's what demons are known for.
Okay, use item, select item.
Oh, I guess like...
I don't know.
Alright.
Oh.
Wait, what do these do?
Open up!
Please!
Quickly!
And these demons end their lack of morals.
Alright.
Yay!
Okay, I had a feeling I could break these.
I'm, like, wondering if, in the original Onimusha games,
like, the items will start sparkling.
And there's hidden items.
So I'm, like, I hope I didn't miss anything.
I never thought I'd make it back here alive.
And don't they have Oh, is it really that bad out there?
There's nothing but fiends and horror beyond here.
If you mean to pass through, I urge you reconsider.
Fiends, huh?
Just what I'm looking for.
All right.
More things to stab.
Beast.
The malice is thickest over there.
Oh, this is where Okay, this is where the demo This is where
the demo started I remember this now Yeah, this is where the
demo started Use me when I check the map It was right here I
will say I did get absolutely destroyed It's not going to be
very pretty I will spoil you right now I got absolutely
destroyed with whatever is that's gonna come our way it's
not gonna go so well it I may or may not have not a lot of
faith in myself surely it won't happen the second time but
surely surely dookie has learned oh um It's alright.
She's gonna go to heaven It's alright guys.
Don't worry.
She's gonna go to heaven at least we know hell and if
there's a hell time user's a heaven Just remember that
That's okay.
I'm pretty sure she'll have a happier life up there Hey guys
I have assisted.
It's so unfortunate that she died before I could help her.
It's so sad.
It's very sad that that happened, guys.
Oh, whoops.
Very unfortunate.
That was fun.
I'll never know what she wanted me to do.
all right right if only I oh shit don't worry I have it oh
wait there is there's the item oh blocked they didn't expect
it because I never blocked any other time
Piss off Ah, yes My favorite samurai motto I can't believe
Guys, if you guys didn't know The British actually stole
that From the samurai I don't know if you guys knew that But
it originally It originated in Japan Line at the sunrise
ain't it
You're just fuel for the goldmills Alright don't worry Don't
worry We're gonna Boom!
Oh fuck!
Oh fuck Okay how is I supposed to know he's gonna do a heavy
attack Oh shit Okay I'll get him Oh How do I get up there?
Oh, that way
You think they got me Yes,
right You don't matter.
Oh, wait, that's actually convenient.
Let me just slowly Oh, I could have done that you think I
did this?
Oh I didn't hit those I don't think they're gonna get me oh
wait it's the other way
you think you're gonna pierce my heart you're gonna get me
oh shit all right nice and then double slash we're done here
all right and then we gotta examine I got I'm gonna sharpen
my knife.
Enhance the equipment.
Alright, let me actually...
Someone was like, please do this.
And I was like, what do you mean?
Do what?
Tips.
Let's see.
Combat.
Alright.
Oh, this.
No.
I mean.
I'll try.
Anything you cannot carry will be sent to your store.
Access it or use to replenish.
I feel like I already have.
Reduce this health and stamina damage from...
In the other row.
Why do that when I can just press X?
Reduce this health, stamina, and for a short duration.
I need to keep all of this for what's going to come after.
what's it's it's not pretty it is not pretty over there all
right why is the oh i guess that okay this one is what's it
doing well i
mean ptsd
Oh shit What the fuck Oh my god my only vision
I vaguely remember this Sorry I got my ass kicked Oh yeah I
remember this Sorry I got my ass kicked so hard At the end
of the demo That like
That's This blurred.
They all blur together.
The power of the ornate is within your eyes as well.
It must have been awakened by that PTSD.
What was that thing?
Yeah, what was it?
The concentration of the malice in this area, along with
memories of the cruelty that created it.
To purify this temple, you will need to find the source of
this vision.
Right.
Gormant lady.
Enough of that.
If you're awake, I've got questions.
I refuse.
What?
You...
You listen here.
Women.
Am I?
Oh, she's a lady.
Yeah!
You gotta be a gentleman!
But now I am not.
Damn, I should have asked politely, bro.
That's not how I...
You speak to a lady.
Alright.
Yeah, always listen to your...
She's always right.
He broke the first rule.
Oh my god.
You gotta remember.
She's always right, bro.
You're not talked back to her.
You know what he could have said?
My mom was right about you.
Trying to tell me something.
Are you ready to make your relationship stronger?
Say that to your lady friend.
My mom was right about you.
That would save any relationship.
Bro.
Alright, hold to make visible that which is hidden team will
go brightly when hidden objects.
Oh, wait, that's interesting.
Oh, oh yeah, I remember this.
I remember this.
This thing's making the threats.
That's this was a unique.
That's an alt.
I'm going to alt real quick.
Your mom would agree.
Okay.
Where is that?
Doki, can you pause?
make a call real quick uh against weapon attacks lb wait
what i'm not involved the farmer but in the ladder okay what
uh unarmed oh unarmed attacks is better with b okay uh and
the ladder oh my god see guys this is what i meant i got so
overwhelmed arrows and may be neutralized by parrying or
deflected back towards oh i could deflect it Okay.
And I could do that, or...
Oh shit!
He kicked!
Alright, there you go.
Press X or Y during a blade barrage.
What?
Oh my god, what is...
Blade barrage?
Oh my god, we're a sap, we're parrying!
We're actually gonna fucking attempt a parry!
Alright, watch this.
Oh, okay, wait.
Oh, come on!
I want to deflect it right out of!
Okay, wait.
Okay, whatever, I'm coming in.
Okay.
That's the power of...
Why?
Then, then when you, what you start, you press the other,
when you start the barrage wave.
Oh, so it's like X, Y, Y, Y.
It's Jedi time.
All right, let me, let me look at that tip again.
Okay, during crossing, okay, and then to break a blade,
you'll need to initiate.
So if there's a one, I press Y, and if it's, oh, okay, but
then, oh, but that's to break it, though.
I have to do it and then break it.
Okay, I see.
Oh, Perry with the X.
Oh my god.
Guys, this is a lot.
Apparently I missed an item already.
I hope it lets you do that forever.
That would be crazy.
I don't think it will.
Because it said it'll get, it'll be like, it'll guarantee a
loss if you do it.
forever that actually miss an item are you guys fucking with
me am I getting baited I feel I'm getting baited I got
baited I was like I don't see it I mean the game just
launched today I don't know I was like an hour I didn't take
an hour to start the game.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, let's hope the items were not that important then.
Yes, it might not be that important.
It might not be that important.
There's no items in the...
Okay, it's this way.
Who knows?
You're right.
Who knows if I am getting baited or not?
X, X.
That's right!
Oh, what?
They lost!
Pissed off.
Okay.
Wait.
You didn't expect a wide, did you?
They really aren't taking prisoners.
Alright.
Wait.
Oh, shit.
I'm trying to parry this.
Oh, fuck.
Give me a sec.
We're gonna figure it out.
Okay, wait.
Oh my god, give me a second.
I'm gonna figure it out.
We're gonna figure this out.
Okay, that's it.
I'm killing you.
No challenge.
Alright.
I wanted to parry it back.
It was my test subject.
We don't have it.
Okay, never mind.
I didn't realize I didn't have the parry mechanic yet.
You get four more.
Love, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
After returning to reality, congratulations on surviving
more important work cause and an impressive shout out.
Oh, we have an awesome stream.
Love, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you again for hanging out with me.
Okay.
Nice.
You got that.
That's right.
You don't expect that.
Why?
See, I baited them.
They were like, that's Doki Burge.
She only matches X.
That's right.
You have to parry, but not deflect.
What does that even mean?
Alright.
Alright, there you go.
Okay, and then suck.
I don't know if they made the demo longer or...
Or, like, made the demo shorter.
Because, like, this does feel longer.
than the demo itself.
Yeah, I need to remember to use...
Oh wait, here.
I need to remember to use my Bs instead of my LB.
Yeah, demo is definitely shorter, because I was like, I do
not remember this part.
It definitely did not take me that long to get to the...
Another one.
Oh, watermelon.
Alright, where is it?
It's over here.
A threat is over here.
I guess I've got to go around the back.
Alright, it is around the back.
Alright.
The Imperator Deflect is unlocked through story.
It's...
It's like through here?
No?
Oh, it's through here.
I mean, I know you're here.
I literally saw you.
Is it the same as the dead?
demo?
I can't remember.
I don't remember it being this long.
We promised if you have... Oh, no.
I played it at Capcom.
Like at uh...
Let's see.
And I'll cut it.
Oh, there must have been a... There must be another one
somewhere.
Is that not the only one?
Yeah.
Okay, it locks this area.
Uh, because I played the one that was shown at um... At New
York Comic-Con.
I heard?
Oh, there's like little spirits here yeah i think the new
york comic con was a lot shorter i remember it was because i
don't remember this part yeah that one was like uh a year
ago more than a year ago that demo hope it won't open from
this side okay
looks like it stretches out behind the building all right
let's see is there anything here okay just to like refresh
my healers if i ever need to heal
all right oh if i don't blow my stick don't move too quickly
oh
don't worry all right x that's right oh wait i can up oh
wait those random red souls floating it's time to suck I
didn't realize They're like orphan souls Where did they go?
They're homeless Oh my god Those red souls earlier were
homeless souls Oh they're so vulnerable Wait Oh where's your
parents little guys
Come over here
They're homeless Give them a home.
Okay, Batman.
What?
I'm like Batman.
I'm adopting them.
They have no home.
I didn't realize they were just homeless.
Where are the homeless souls?
Oh my god, they're God.
Batman.
I'm Batman.
but better.
Oh no, they ran away.
Look at that.
That scares them away.
You're being adopted.
Please do not resist.
Why would they?
I'll give them a home in my arm.
What better place would they want to be in?
Alright.
To earn favor.
Offer it at Anna's Hall to earn favor.
What's that?
Okay, there's some free stuff.
In the old Onimushi game, it was like tank controls and
everything.
So this is definitely...
Is a lot different.
Oh, break loss.
Okay.
Let me show you there's nothing here.
No, this was definitely not in the demo.
But one guy!
You're the attackers here.
Okay, that's fine.
All right.
We got this.
Be careful of the one guy!
Remember to go one by one because it's not... It'll be rude.
What the fuck?
Guys, it'll be rude if it wasn't...
Damn, the chain attack.
It's very nice, though, that they...
Okay, that's not fair.
That's not fair.
I locked on the wrong person.
No!
That's okay.
I don't need a heal.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Give me a sec.
I need a heal.
Guys, there's so many people!
Okay, maybe I do need a heal.
Okay.
Oh my god, this is actually bullshit.
It's okay.
Chain attack!
Okay, this is a...
Wait, actually, I didn't even realize there was an archer
here.
Alright, that's fine.
Chain attack!
There we go.
Nobody ever expects a chain attack!
all right it's because of the archers guys it was because of
the archers that threw me off all right there you go easy
didn't need a heal at all He just used the X combo toky.
Guys, it's because the archers threw me off the groove.
It's all because of the archers.
The moment I got rid of the archer, I fell back in.
I got back into the groove.
I fell back into the routine.
Can I open this?
I should be able to.
That should be a shortcut, right?
Oh my god, I won't open for this side.
I actually need this, though.
Oh, thank god they're dead.
That means it's not illegal to steal from them.
Because it's not stealing.
It's not stealing.
Because they're not alive.
Alright.
I'm just making sure their items have a home.
You know?
Caring for the homeless.
okay where is it that was it for items all right you missed
the rooms and salad of the houses earlier oh or by the
extract yellow souls from those they strike down rmb when
the only go gauge is sufficiently filled only deplete the
only power gauge in order to unleash special attacks for
example the two Celestials.
Well, it's your strain of special to extract yellow souls.
Kind of reminds me of the Gornut.
Did the Oni make these two?
How do I use it, though?
Oh, I can only use it when... Oh, I can only use it when
it's like that.
Apparently I missed some items.
Okay, how do I get back?
It's so...
Okay, it's right here.
Yeah, so they're heel daggers.
Yeah, this was not...
in the this was not in the uh new york comic con demo i only
had a sword
yeah it's not called gray robbing it's repurposing
that actually what what
did i did i got baited that did i got baited Did I...
Oh, Doki, it was that room, Doki.
Show me what you thought.
Wait a minute.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's five.
Oh shit!
What the fuck?
Alright.
Wait a minute.
Oh my god.
Shit!
Okay, this is a lot harder.
Okay.
Alright, there we go.
I don't know what to fight.
Don't keep fighting back.
Alright.
Wait, what was the room that he opened?
I don't even...
What room did he even open?
Where did he come from?
Explore the...
Was it here?
Oh my god, it's these rooms.
There was nothing here.
Oh, wait.
There you go.
I got the pair.
Was it worth it?
Guys, I got the pair.
Was that what you wanted me to get?
The con- Yeah, the conventions had a different demo.
Because they wanted- You only had, like, 30 minutes to play.
So it was, like, it led me straight to, like, the center.
So I know I had- When I said I got my ass kicked.
I knew exactly where I got my ass kicked.
Like, don't worry.
That memory is, like, in my head.
Burned into my head.
Yeah.
I don't have this box.
Yeah, I was going to say this box looks like it's breakable.
Because after the 30 minute is done, like, like, it doesn't
matter where you're at in the game.
So it was like, you had 30 minutes to get there.
That's why I was like, I do not remember.
I don't remember any of this.
I...
Yeah, the combat is very complex.
I think it's just like all the dodge, the different dodges
you have to do.
I just need to get used to it.
I'm so...
I'm like Ungabunga.
The thing is, I'm just Ungabunga right now.
I'm very Ungabunga pilled.
I think the more I play, I'll be less Ungabunga.
But right now, I just want to...
Oh, there was nothing here.
Where the fuck am I supposed to go?
Did I go back?
Wait, what's this?
Oh, there's treasure.
Yeah.
Yeah, there's a lot of people that go through at a
convention.
So, that's why, like, it's timed.
Or, like, exactly how much.
Okay.
How do I get there?
There is treasure over here.
Oh, was it here?
What do I get?
there oh it's wait what okay is there like a no there's no
openings here okay i thought i was being baited i thought
there's like a secret pack secret hole yeah it won't open
from this side oh my god how do i have to like go oh it's
from here uh i guess it unlocked the gate right Is that the
backtrack?
I'm pretty sure I just had the backtrack.
How different is this one?
This is very different from the original game.
Like, the original game was very...
Resident Evil, Tank Control Corp.
A giant Kenma eats everything.
If you...
If he hears this...
How many he hears this?
Thank God.
Thank God they're hearing is a little bad.
I'm gonna sneak in.
I have no idea where they...
Hello?
Whoa!
How did they know?
What's the point of sneaking in?
Is that it?
Yes, that's it.
Alright.
Oh yeah, Jube!
But yeah, um, it was like tank controls and it's fixed
cameras.
Um, and then in, I don't know if they're going to introduce
more weapons, but in the original I can swap weapons.
Like, the thing about, uh, Onimusha in the original games is
that there were like a lot of weapons I could use and abuse.
Okay, I'm actually have to look at the map here.
I'm so confused.
I wonder if I...
Go this way.
I will... if I can open this door.
Holy shit!
Oh my god, you think she'll be okay?
You think?
At least he opened the door.
Oh my...
Oh, she'll be fine.
New wife, I guess.
Alright, let's see.
I go this way.
and then she'll be okay.
Damn monsters.
I mean, they didn't kill her.
They didn't kill her right off.
Why are you kidding me?
I pressed!
Oh my god, I pressed it!
Okay, that's illegal!
Okay, there you go.
It's fine.
It's just fine.
I'm so mad.
I'm so, I'm so mad.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that's it.
That's it.
Alright, it's fine.
We're okay.
I'm mad now.
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine, it's fine.
I can open that too.
Alright, we have to go.
Okay, I want to get that treasure.
She got so mad that she buried.
That's when you know.
Oh my god, there's treasure there.
At the counter, the counter for it is like, oh my gosh, the
timing.
It's just everything is time.
Everything is timing.
So it's, I'm like, it fucks with me a lot.
Okay.
I need a tie.
I had to pair it.
I could pair it with X.
I can pair it with B.
I can pair it with L1.
I'm back here.
I need to get used to it.
Alright.
Let's see.
Does it re- I don't know if the shrine respawns monsters.
That's what I'm most worried about.
Is anyone ahead of me right now?
That can confirm.
Oh, so we can.
Yeah, we can't do this.
Is it bonfire shrine or a normal shrine?
God, I can't access that.
It did?
Okay, so it does.
Okay, so now that's good to know.
It's a bonfire shrine.
Okay, I'm not going to do it then.
I don't want to deal with that.
Yeah, no, I'm fine.
I've cleared it.
I've cleared enough.
Alright, so it is a bonfire shrine.
Uh...
Wait, I go this way.
Oh my god, did I just unlocked another bonfire?
Oh, it doesn't matter anyway.
I'm just, I guess...
I guess we're respawning them anyway.
Fuck it.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter what travel.
I guess I'm here.
I'm here right now.
That treasure was bait.
Not gonna lie.
What is that?
Where is that temple?
I don't know where that area is.
Wait, I should save.
Examining doesn't respond to him.
Inactivate it for the just don't rest.
Well, it's too late.
If they already respawned.
I don't see them, though.
Oh.
Another one.
Oh, is it here?
Oh.
Suck.
Oh, he's so sad.
I am enjoying the game so far.
I am getting fucked up by all the parries.
And so, because, like, Movement, you gotta use...
You gotta use B.
Sword attacks, you gotta use...
X or...
L1.
It's fucking me up.
Grabs is also B.
Please.
Help me.
Right behind you.
Oh no, is he sacrificing?
I'm not dead!
He could be a demon.
Hey!
Oh shit!
The demons made him do it.
Oh, I guess they, like, all sacrificed their kids.
Oh, there!
This is him.
Oh, my God.
Does he also...
He also... Oh, my God.
No one's special now.
I guess no one...
one special.
Zenomake, thank you for the raid.
They didn't go.
We had a great stream.
This thing's made me so damn strong.
I've been bored halfway back to death.
When did they start mass-producing gauntlets?
But look, you got yourself one.
Yeah, they're handing them out like cereal boxes.
Like cereal box prize.
said luck you get it on here and you get okay i got okay i i
don't know how i wish would stop you at least oh my god okay
you thought that cut through too bad who the hell wears a
metal hat
what okay oh nicely done Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I'm dodging it?
I'm not dying.
Ah!
Shit!
Oh, never mind.
No!
You cannot be done already.
It's just like in the demo.
Just like in the demo.
Okay, it's...
Guys, it was a strategy.
Just can't stop us.
I wish it would stop you at least.
Oh my gosh, you're Chris Wise.
You thought that would cut through?
Too bad.
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
Guys, I was just strategizing.
It's a tactic so I get all my HP back.
Are you fucking...
So slow.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Goodbye.
Why do I stop to put up with you?
Exactly.
So true.
Are you kidding me?
How do I stop?
Oh, my God.
Thank you.
I'm trying so hard to parry I'm trying okay okay okay all
right we're gonna focus on parrying keep dodging hit and run
where we left off death can't stop us are you impressed oh
my god there you go put your back in switch you thought that
would cut through too bad my turn my turn my turn Who the
hell wears a...
He's such a hater.
I love it.
Lost your nerve.
Scared.
Okay.
Are you...
I really have gotten too strong.
Why is this goblin bigger?
Okay.
The metal hat does help, too.
Alright, I don't go first.
least all right i'm
just getting started you thought that would cut through okay
are you kidding what lost your nerve scared all right
all right it's fine it's fine i can't okay Oh!
I really have gotten too strong.
Okay, I'm locked.
I'm gonna focus up.
I'm focusing up.
It's so hard to parry this.
The timing is so weird.
The timing is so fucking weird.
Left off.
Death can't stop us.
I wish it would stop you at least.
You thought that'll cut through?
Okay.
Too bad.
Who the hell wears a metal hat?
Oh my God, you fucking bitch.
Okay.
We both died.
Why do I stop the pill?
I know, right?
Things would have been so boring if we ended there.
And I'm not gonna miss a chance to cut each other to shred.
Okay.
All right.
Locked in now.
What?
Stop!
I'm right here!
Okay.
What could be more?
Alright.
Okay, I'm locked in.
Oh my god, you fucking whore!
Nobody loves you!
No!
I'm...
Yes, yes, this is what I wanted.
I need it.
This dance with death.
Oh, my God!
Same story!
Why does he get all of that?
At least pretend to try.
You're weak, weak so damn weak, you fraud.
Why?
Why does his only gauntlet have all of that?
Right where he left off.
Death can't stop us.
I wish it would stop you.
Okay.
You thought that cut through?
Too bad!
Okay.
Who the hell wears a metal hat?
Oh my...
What could be more fun than dancing with death?
Oh my god, I should not have done that.
Okay, it's fine.
It's a tactical...
It's done!
It's tactical so I can heal!
You bitch.
Okay.
Are you serious?
You look terrible, Masashi.
Oh my god, he's dodging me too!
No!
That's it?
That's all you've got.
How do I dodge that?
Oh.
Alright.
Right where we left off.
Death can't stop us.
I wish it would stop you at least.
I swear to God.
Take this.
Do you thought that would cut through?
Too bad.
Okay.
Who the hell wears a metal hat?
Alright.
That's fine.
Oh my god, that's so fine!
That's so fine!
It's so hot!
Oh.
That's fine.
Swing.
Swing batter, batter.
Oh.
Oh, this is fun.
Lost all nicely done.
That's right.
Okay, select your press, then press.
Use the select target, then press X or Y your target.
Head.
Headshot.
Woohoo!
That's done.
What a thrill.
Riots more mistakes anymore you stupid bastard I gotta
imagine now Oh Time to finish you are
Not today yet, please heal Take this
oh okay died why do i stop to put up with you things would
have been so boring are you kidding me are you kidding me i
got so greedy i got so greedy tall i got so greedy there i
wanted to heal i was like where we left off
least all right are you serious why can't i do that okay
it's fine okay that that's an eye frame at least i know
that's an eye frame metal hat oh my god are you you look
terrible missashi
Oh my god, keep forgetting he combos that.
Guys, it was not pretty.
I told you it was not good.
It was not good for me.
Ah!
You're weak, weak, so damn weak, you are wrong.
I don't, please!
Oh, nicely done.
I've gotten too strong.
Oh my god!
okay right where we left off dead can't stop us i wish i
started with why first nobody expects why too bad who the
hell was a missile are you kidding me
are you kidding me he does that okay we both died why do i
stop the pill I swear to God guys to finish you off.
I swear to God.
I parry Swing
Okay That's it that's all you got I'm gonna figure out the
timing.
I'm gonna figure out the timing for his stabs.
That's it.
All right, we're gonna practice this.
He's gonna I'm gonna practice this All right, all right, do
your swings I'll catch this in my parish.
I wish it would stop you at least.
Come on.
Do it.
Oh, yeah.
Is that your best?
You thought that would cut through?
Too bad.
Who the hell wears a metal hat?
Okay, there you go.
What?
Okay!
Oh my god, I swear to God That It's so unforgiving It's so
unforgiving I swear It's so unforgiving The dodging is Oh my
god, the timing Is where we left off The timing for this I
wish it would stop you at least Oh put your back into it you
thought that was cut through too bad who the hell wears a
metal hat there you go okay ah looking of course i always
forget that he does that
okay we both died why do i stop the i know right things
would have been so boring if we and i'm not gonna miss a
chance to cut each other to Okay.
Oh my god, I ate you so much.
Yeah.
Oh, there you go.
Got you!
What?
Oh my god.
You're weak, weak, so damn weak.
I hate him so much.
I hate him.
Oh, nicely done.
I broke his hat.
Okay.
There you go.
That's it.
That's all you've got.
You know who I realize he sounds like?
He sounds like Kuro.
He knew when he says that.
I realized I was like, I've heard this voice, but this
really sounds like Kira.
I was like, right where we left off, death can't stop us.
I wish we'd stop you at least.
Yeah, this entire time I realized.
You look terrible, Masashi.
Oh my god, I'm sad.
Is that your best?
You thought that he cut through?
Too bad.
Who the hell wears a metal hat?
Oh, okay.
Okay, nice.
Oh, nicely done.
Nice.
Oh, ah!
What?
Lost your nerve?
Scared?
Yes.
Okay.
I need to learn his combos.
There we go.
No!
He stabs right there!
I'm back!
Oh,
I see.
This is like the filter boss.
This is actually the...
Okay.
Right where we left off.
Death can't stop us.
I wish we'd stop you.
I told you guys.
Two.
you thought that would cut through too bad who the hell
wears a metal hat oh my god this is the tension you can feel
it oh my god dodge almost everything too why do i stop the
put up with you i know right things would have been so
boring if we ended there and i'm not gonna miss a chance to
cut each other to Oh my god, fucking horde.
Okay.
All right.
He does!
Oh, the one time!
Oh, I'm getting too aggressive now.
I'm getting too aggressive now.
No, you cannot.
be done already oh my god i told you i remember this fight
very clearly at right where we your god my god death can't
stop us i wish it would stop you at least
we both died why do i still have to put up with you okay oh
my god you bitch okay that's it and i'm not gonna miss a
chance to cut each other to shreds all right yeah i'm just
getting started you thought that cut through too bad who the
hell wears a metal hat
all right i'm full focusing swing swing batter batter oh you
i pressed it i pressed it oh you
I really have gotten too strong Alright, I'm full Okay, I'm
fully locked in I'm fully locked in No commentary Right
where we left off Death can't stop us I wish we'd stop you
at least You thought that would cut through Too bad Who the
hell wears a metal hat Oh my god.
That's me.
I'm right here.
What?
No!
That's all you got.
Dope.
No items.
I don't need items.
I don't need- I need a- items are only amusha five where we
left on death can't stop us i wish it would stop you at
least me too i do too who the hell wears a metal hat all
right he got you
i pressed circle
you don't turn around stop the put up with me
all right so slow okay take this this okay All right, there
we go.
Oh, this is fine.
There we go.
Second pair.
Okay.
I need to suck this up.
Oh, nicely done.
No!
No, you cannot be done already.
I need to circle!
I swear to God, I'm pressing circle.
I'm pressing circle.
Right.
Where we left off, death can't stop us.
I wish it would stop you at least.
Me too.
Is that your best?
You thought that was not true?
Okay.
Too bad.
Who the hell wears a metal hat?
Nice.
Oh my god, Sticky Perry.
that enough got you okay all right there you go there you go
you both died why do i start to put up with you i know right
things would have been so boring if we ended there and i'm
not gonna miss a chance to get okay holy shit i didn't mean
to do that of this let's go missachi oh there you go
headshot oh nicely done
okay okay that was that was bullshit what could be more fun
than dancing with death oh my god he got me swing he's got
me Time to finish you off Okay No, no, no, no, no, no I'm
greedy, I'm getting greedy again, I'm getting greedy again
Okay No, no Oh, oh, oh
Okay One hit Yeah Oh, my God.
No.
Damn it.
I've had this cursed thing.
So many can muscles.
Holy shit.
This isn't what you promised gauntlet.
Oh, my God.
Please, my peace.
your hat.
Dump.
The stupid metal hat.
Bastard.
What's your game, damn it?
I was too...
That gauntlet there used to be mine.
A word to the wise, but...
Finally, I'm out of doom to the alley.
Genma, all well and good.
Oh my god, that was the first boss.
I'm so scared.
Why not get...
it a try nothing quite like a happy gauntlet oh my god he's
gonna feed
it's not
fair oh my god This will do!
Oh my god, this guy really sounds like Kuro.
He sounds just like him.
Oh no, no.
Please!
I've been through so much!
Get a hold of yourself!
Oh my god, he's drunk!
Are you a man or a beast?
Does it matter?
A beast doesn't far from an onion, you know?
Oh,
no, he's gonna smell your lady.
I would stop talking if I were you.
You wanted to get stronger now.
Think of a five-year-old ship.
Think of a super chat.
Thank you.
God damn it.
Oh.
That's the spirit.
I'm letting it corrupt me.
Damn it.
he's like smell you later oh my god i this the parry was
this is so hard this is so hard to parry with just regular x
i wonder if it's like okay i must have to like do like oh my
gosh it's the timing the timing for x parry is so difficult
it's easy and it's like you can't Oh my gosh.
If you spam your buttons too much, you can't cancel it too.
Do you think you would be the super chat thing?
You can't like, you can't cancel the X.
So if you spammed it, you can't just do like this to...
It's such a tight window.
Oh, it's so hard.
All right.
We have to go this way.
Is there any items though?
He's already lost it now.
Are you missing items?
Okay, I knew it.
I knew there was something there.
Okay, I need to grab water.
I'm so dehydrated from that.
I Yeah, no, Snowy, thank you so much.
Oh, it was all the pain was all Snowy, thank you so much for
the 50 gift of chips.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much for the support.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
The pain was all worth it.
metal hat it's goddamn fucking stupid metal hat and it was
all worth it I feel like I was supposed to use items for
that match maybe just just maybe the increased help gems
restorative maybe I was supposed to use it and who the hell
Where is a meta?
No, exactly.
That's cheating.
It's a 1v1.
I was so pumped for phase two.
What a letdown.
Crystal, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah, I'm saving it for Onimusha 5, guys.
Don't worry.
It'll all carry over.
Oh, fuck that guy.
Oh my god.
No wonder his mother didn't love him growing up.
Another dark mess.
Guess it's all I've got to go on.
Alright, suck it up.
This is Onimusha 5.
Sorry, Onimusha 6.
I lost count.
Oh, shit.
It's when they threw like the children.
Or like sacrifices, right?
Yeah.
Blood for the blood god.
Guys, now you know why I had so much trauma.
But I was like, I definitely remember the boss.
But...
Why would demon souls get...
me less power than human souls like that's up do you not see
this man how am i like 20 times stronger than gary i know
they smell yeah i get it now yeah what me it's not a vision
all right hold let's get your glyphs only decipherable to
the only to read them yes use how to reveal oh i'm gonna
learn how to read guys how do i know acting up again let's
go i guess what my thing is time to read
what's this what the fuck what is this
the eye of swan wait what if there's stuff over there the
only way is forward it looks like The only way is for it
goes back.
I want to be sure I didn't miss anything.
I just want to be sure.
I guess it wasn't the only way.
There has to be stuff here, right?
I want to be sure.
There has to be items here.
Okay, where did I come from?
There might be stuff here, maybe.
I want to be sure to miss out.
See, I told you.
I knew it.
Got watermelon.
Nice.
I knew there were hidden items.
It wouldn't be a Capcom game without it.
Wait, oh, I thought there'd be stuff here.
Oh, why make a hole here?
They don't put anything secret.
Oh.
Yeah.
That's a Capcom game.
There's always hidden items.
And I came from up there.
Now I can go.
Take me.
Ah!
Flashbang.
Surely she won't flashbang us again.
My eyes.
Alright.
There we go.
Gold?
Oh, follow the God.
All right.
Continues through the cave.
A temple.
Did the Gamma build it?
Hard to imagine.
Oops.
Oh, all right.
Let's save.
And I'm going to grab water real quick, guys.
I'll be right back.
It is very beautiful.
Surely, I don't think there's, like, monsters here.
So I'm going to stand right here.
I'll be back.
the first boss has to be like the filter boss where you have
to learn the game like you're like you're like gotta learn
this like you think you think you can just spam x all the
time today's that day like they're like you you think you're
able to just spam x and never parry that that was the filter
boss 100 percent Yeah, he had the skill, like, sink or swim.
We know what you are.
Hachuke, Song, Tom, Sekra, Vince, Papa, On Stuffed Solid.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's not that kind of game, Toki.
I'm like, no, my strat.
learn all three different kinds of parries oh oh i'm so
scared of the other bosses guys i i'm really worried now i'm
so worried oh you think you're oh you're so comfy you think
you're safe what about the grass I had never played Sekiro
before, by the way, Crystal.
They give a super chat.
So I don't know.
I have never played Sekiro.
Can't believe they let you fight the last boss in the
beginning.
A powerful bow made by the Oni.
Blessed are the endless.
Oh, it can be summoned at any time.
Used to attack enemies and activate certain objects from
areas or particular when targeting specific body parts.
Increase the damage.
Alright, gun time.
Find his keepers.
I think it'd be easier to play with mouse and keyboard.
Wait, where?
How do I move?
What if I start playing with mouse and key just because they
have an arrow?
Don't it.
Surely.
this isn't hell or the living world what is this place only
refuge oh it's where they're born and it's where babies come
from this is where the demon babies come from
okay i mean a faster reaction time when it comes to mnk
whoops okay but imagine if i could headshot that though What
the fuck?
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Alright, suck.
Alright, whoa, wait, wait, wait, wait.
We gotta suck this.
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me suck this.
Oh my god.
okay you must see guys it's very i'm not a controller player
when it comes to aiming i can go up here right all right
wait is there all right this is for high ground okay i gotta
make sure there's no hidden items here all right high ground
a lesser soul crystal i assume this soul crystal is like for
the soul crystal is for more souls.
I can use that to like upgrade my weapons later.
Oh, there's the big guy.
Those rocks.
But can I hit that?
Shoot the cores within the cluster bringing them crash.
Oh, so there's environmental kills too.
Alright.
It's nice.
Oh, and it resets the Nope, because it's a magic rock.
Yep, that's how it works.
Thank God for magic rocks.
Nice.
Okay, so if I fuck up the first time, I get a...
They're like, you could try and want to try again.
It's good to know.
You're just fuel for the coordinates.
Gendler got the one in the place here too.
That made it easy.
Nice.
And I know I don't have to charge that.
Alright.
Oh shit, you're still alive.
Hey, let me play an FPS game real quick.
Actually, it would be easier if I walk up to them.
There you go.
Combo!
Oh, I wish there was, like, um, Kalat.
Oh, thank God.
This feels so much easier with whatever the fuck I was in,
like, with that boss fight.
I...
It's, like, like, walk at the park now.
I feel like I'm...
I have to learn how to run and I'm back to crawling.
It's like, all right, Doki, now you go back to your training
wheels.
Yippee!
I remember you're like, hey, I know you were just born, it's
time to get your driver's license.
Alan, think of a super chat thing you think and never forget
the secret of fun.
Because now that you got your driver's license, you can go
back to your little, you can go, oh, hey, cool.
You can go back with your little tricycle.
Oh, all right.
Boop.
Powerstone.
Might can be used to enhance basic skills.
The environment's beautiful though.
The lore building, the world building, and lore building.
Got something nearby to show me.
Where is it?
Harvest.
Here?
Do I have to learn to read again?
Where?
Where must I read?
Oh, it's over there.
Alright, reading time.
Hello?
No.
Oh.
My game crashed.
I hope there was auto save I guess I was just like
What do you mean I saved When was there a shrine?
Oh no Oh no Even the game The game was like No no time no
it's not time to read okay you're not ready for that you're
not ready to read you're you're not ready oh my god I hope I
hope it I hope it's not too far away I hope oh it's
okay I'm just sending my report don't worry cap write this
down Capcom.
Write this down.
I'm still sending in the report right now.
Alright, here we go.
Come on.
Oh my god, how long is it to...
I'm sending my data to Capcom right now.
No way.
Capcom.
It's taking a while.
Fuck it.
Don't Capcom.
You're not getting this data.
I canceled it.
JK, I canceled it.
They didn't get my data.
Alright, here I am rebooting.
Yes.
Yes!
Oh my god, why did I cancel?
Now it's taking fucking, okay, I need a force quit it.
Oh my god, now it's gonna take, it's taking forever.
Because it's like, sorry, let me give us a sec.
Now that you're forcing us to cancel, we're gonna have you
wait even longer.
Alright.
I don't, stop, stop, report, stop, stop the report, stop the
report.
There's nothing to report.
Everything's fine.
Oh my god, what did that accident?
Okay.
Close the crash report.
End task.
Alright.
There you go.
It's okay.
Capcom.
Everything's fine.
Oh, please.
Oh, please tell me it'll be okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Guys, it's syncing up the cloud data.
It still thinks Oni Mousha is being read.
all right it's okay i'm stopping it surely all save will be
okay oh please be okay please please please don't make me do
this please please auto save please oh please by the way
this game is pretty for me okay to be fair it's really hard
to tell when my i will say my pc is very um
a lot of uh good parts so it's very hard to tell if it is
optimized but for me it seems optimized
it seems pretty optimized for me yeah my my rig is beefy
but i i'm also running my skin suit running myself on there
yeah but i'm also using v tube studio v bridger and oni
musha but for some for for now everything seems to be okay
in terms of like optimization because i've had games where i
would be like oh come on don't do this to me i don't only
okay here it is the moment of truth where did it leave me
the where did it leave me the moment of truth oh thank god
okay okay okay it's just time oh thank god i just have to
read all right now all right time to read for real this time
just when you think you've seen it all right okay we're fine
it looks beautiful especially on the msi monitor anyway
remember to check out the MSI monitor, guys.
It really does help support the stream and this channel and
MSI.
Thank you to MSI for the sponsor.
And there might be stuff up here.
I knew it.
If there's, like, a random staircase to nowhere, there's
always stuff there.
It looks amazing with my MSI monitor.
And we can be Twinsies.
We can be these guys if you get the same money as me we'd be
the same all
right here we go
it's just very hungry guys speeding time has the sound been
great so far oh my gosh have you already been streamed for
three hours this game is actually really fun i've been
enjoying it so far other than that one one part of the game
i've been other than that one part i've been joining it so
far
That hungry gunman must be through there.
That one section where they were like, stop learning how to
swim, Doki.
I was like, wait, wait, that was just boring.
Oh.
This again.
You don't have to move it to get through.
I assume like I have to climb up the ladder.
Does conveniently place ladder?
I'm sure that's part of this puzzle somehow.
Is conveniently placed ladder.
Oh, an addition.
Oh, reading time.
I learned to read.
Alright, and...
I bet the Genma have had a hard time figuring all this out.
Maybe that's the point, huh?
Where the fuck am I?
Oh, I'm lost.
Oh, no.
Wait, wait, it's just one pathway.
Okay, there you go.
I love this conveniently placed ladder in my...
What?
No, it's not.
There we go.
I'm not stupid.
Don't question that, guys.
Alright, this isn't my first puzzle.
That's fucking right.
Nothing is truly a dead end.
Alright, here we go.
Where is the belly with legs?
Alright.
Unlocked.
Save.
Well, this looks like a boss, but...
This feels very boss-fighting.
He's like, I'm gonna fight the giant phony.
Eat him!
Fucking absorb him.
Really,
it's gonna be easier, right?
Oh, what?
He's on a hero's mind.
That's fine.
What's my reason to kill him?
Wait.
What are you?
Good question.
I'll get back to you on that one.
Oh, yeah, he's kids.
That's why I need to kill him.
I just gave him a scene.
I was like, why would I need to kill him?
He seems fine.
Just eating other odysseus.
I was like, oh, yeah, he eats children.
What are you laughing at, Piggy?
about that he's a child eater oh he's freaky
put your mouth where your mouth is
bro he's like 50 on my screen i just Oh, you!
Wait, can I just do that?
Okay.
What?
Okay, um, why don't I just do this?
I don't I don't know
Just start sucking up.
I mean oh my god okay i could smell the souls in it from
here i bet it takes great oh my god you take great too i
just want to put the temple back to normal and wake up
gauntlet lady well what killing you gets that done your
death okay that's right now i can stab you oh absorb souls
in order Oh, okay.
Oh, that's not cool.
Not...
Nope.
Really?
Okay.
I'll break his... I'll try and break this.
That's right!
Oh, shit!
I'm trying to fucking absorb this!
Yeah, that's a fucking bomb!
Ah, wait, why do I keep using the bow accidentally?
Okay, okay, okay, I'm focusing up now.
I'm gonna focus up for real.
All right.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
I think I'm okay
It's okay I'll just keep hitting his belly Okay Okay
Okay Okay
this boss just cut his belly open see guys I might have
played her I might have fucked around a bit no thank you for
the raid thank you thank you okay I I might have been just
fucking around I just wanted to shoot him with my bow
but what if I just kept shooting my bow what if Oh Wait, is
this face to you?
Oh shit.
I have no more heals
No, oh No, I fucked up What did you do?
My armor Yeah Oh,
no, oh no, I fucked up again I'm unstoppable.
Oh, yeah?
Oh, yeah.
Maybe that was it.
I swear it again!
Where's the flavor?
Oh!
I pressed circle.
This is it.
This is...
He's drawing power from the those two.
Okay.
Let me eat you already!
Wow!
What happened to me?
Oh!
No!
Okay.
Okay, but what do I do with this?
I got it.
Better eat before he
Because I might not have got it.
I might not have got it.
Oh, shit.
Okay, okay.
Let's see who's hungry.
You.
Okay, okay, now I won't fuck around this time.
I'm starting now.
Starting now.
How what you gonna do when I'm up this platform, huh?
Yeah That's hilarious.
That's right what you gotta do now.
Oh shit
Yeah, oh You mean he could break it
Wait, you mean he can break it My precious armor!
Okay, that's fine.
What?
I pressed!
I pressed circle, guys!
I pressed circle, I swear to god.
So good!
I could eat on the old day!
Okay, here we go.
A full belly meat!
Full power!
Oh, what?
I mean, okay.
All right, it's fine.
It's five.
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's five.
Oh, there you go.
I got a pattern up.
Oh, my God.
I almost got the pattern up.
I thought I did That's an ony gourdlet You got an ony
gourdlet I could smell the soul in it Holy shit I bet it
tastes great I bet you tastes great too I just want to put
the temples back to you Oh my god Where is that Percy?
Oh Oh Oh Guys, I did better when I was...
I will sit.
I did better when I was using the bow.
Who would have died?
I could eat on the old day.
Okay.
There we go.
Jesus Christ, I don't know what's up with me.
Let me take this giant...
Oh my god.
Today.
Oh.
Bo!
My precious Oliver!
There you go.
Bo, Bo, Bo, Bo, Bo!
Bo!
Okay.
This is a little bad because I don't have HP again.
No!
Fuck!
What?
Oh, you're so tasty!
Okay.
Oh, that's not good for me.
Now the real fun starts.
Oh!
No!
That shouldn't hit me, right?
Oh, there we go.
Stop running.
Let me eat you.
Oh, my God.
I swear to God, I was trying to...
Those souls are wasted on you, monster.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I'm far enough I thought I was far enough whoa wow what is
this okay did he grab Bye, Chris Perry!
Don't get ahead of yourself, then, Piggy.
Eddie's took my shield!
Oh my god, I'm so fucked up.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna suck.
Okay, I'll stop fucking around, guys.
way.
I'll stop.
I'll stop fucking this time.
This time.
I'll stop this time.
Let's see who's hungry.
You.
This guy.
This time I'll stop fucking around.
Okay.
I was trying to figure out the pattern here.
Oh, man.
Okay.
The other armor.
We got the other armor.
Woo!
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
There we go.
What?
Okay.
I timed that correctly.
That was timed perfectly.
Oh my god.
Okay, I think I'm fine.
Okay.
I was not fine there.
All right, there you go.
Okay, there you go.
All right.
It's five.
Okay.
Headshot!
You got an odd godlet.
I could smell the souls in it from here.
I bet it tastes great I bet you taste great too.
Oh god.
I just wanted to put the temple back to normal Okay, I wake
up gormant lady here Killing you gets that done.
You're dead.
It's okay Everything is fine Oh Wait, suck?
It sucks.
Oh, please tell me I got the suck!
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I figured it out.
Oh, shit!
Whoops!
A full belly!
back down oh yes yes yes oh shit okay all right i did carry
it though did you guys see it though it was sick when it i
did do it i did do it oh are you trying to make me puke
you've got some clever tricks for a monster okay
That's five
Okay, I saw it.
All right Oh my god no no no no okay get healed get healed
get healed I told you I told you I'd like this I said I
would lock in guys I did not stutter there we go just wanted
to eat
There we go.
I didn't lie.
I didn't lie about that.
Sometimes you eat.
Let's fucking go.
Serials, by the way.
No heal items.
Oh, they got it.
I think got it.
It gave me a cutscene suck.
My wafel?
Zizukula?
Gondlet lady?
First chance!
All right, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I am not living in a gauntlet by choice.
Then what?
No.
Forget that.
Just tell me how to take this thing off.
You still want to say take it off?
Did he not?
Yeah, you're just...
gonna fucking break apart and then go to hell without the
gauntlet you will die literally explained it perfectly he's
just a pile of meat stapled together let us continue this at
rocker duchy temple let us continue this now leaving the
gauntlet with this much malice around is terribly taxing
so sad all he wanted to do was eat people can't even do
anything anymore in this society god you got a name like
gauntlet lady give me something to work with people are just
so sensitive now can't even eat one or two children is
shizuka i expect you to remember it huh what kind of haughty
excuse me excuse me
guys i'm pretty sure in part two i'm gonna forget all the
parries guys i'm just i'm a little worried i'm a little
worried you did well to purify kyomizagara temple masashi i
have no qualms with your performance how do you know i did
well however it seems the situation is worse than i thought
The malice is spreading fast this area is in a terrible
state.
Thank you.
Oh, you're right Wait Oh, no Wait, if it's stuck on his arm
you said the lady in your oh, and it's on his right arm.
Oh Can he can't he can't take it up He left the temple a
friend of yours He's always watching guys If it's the
Shizuka I know, she's one of the race of Oni who rule the
place.
What is she gonna do is stop him?
An Oni?
Yeah, she said Oni?
Yeah.
Whatever the answer to that is, it's nothing good.
And at the rate this malice is spreading its corruption, I
fear the worst.
In any case, we can't know anything for sure until we hear
it from Shizuka herself.
wasashi i have another task for you if you're willing i can
sense that more rifts have opened up in the nearby area more
i'd have you close them for me i don't think shizuka there
will be able to wake up until we thin all this malice she
showed up for 10 for one minute and was like i'm eating now
it should prove useful i mean thank you for the raid thank
you i hope you had a great stream not like i can refuse at
least one of us is getting there resting my name is suzuka
i'm epi goodbye
all right main menu oh now i'm at home base i want my
mission close the wrist okay all right there is a
concentrated malice are dangerous avoid them at all cost
okay so heal oh so i have to avoid i have to make sure i
don't go through this red stuff all right um i have health
and restored when healing oh nice uh oh okay so i get like a
shard of mirror once carried by anna king of hell uh it
resonates with only in guiding your destinations all right
so let me equip stuff all right now i have more healing
which is good Wait a minute.
They said I can...
Okay, I thought they said I can...
New outfits unlock.
Ooh, new clothes?
Can I actually have more?
How do I unlock outfit?
How do I wear this?
I guess not.
Alright, we'll go.
Wait, what does she have to say?
I'm gonna talk to me.
I just don't get it I guess with Oh I have to read it myself
On your store tip I guess with all this Malice around that's
not happening The mouse has opened up rifts everywhere too
Takamura wants you to handle so you better get to work
Alright let's go close these rifts Oh there it is Change my
outfit okay Clothing I guess this is the new one He crawls
Recalls his run Okay, it's not as cool, though.
And I'll keep the current outfit.
It's not as cool.
Alright.
Yeah, what is she doing, huh?
What's her job?
Oh, is this where I...
Oh, I can enhance your charms.
You'll need both red souls and favor.
I don't know if I want to enhance it.
Because I feel like I might get better charms later, so I
feel like it's just a waste, you know?
Like, no one ever enhances the first charm.
I don't know, it feels like a bit of a waste.
Okay, how the fuck do I get out of here?
Okay, I guess I opened this door.
Oh, okay, it doesn't seem bad.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, it seems like a perfectly safe village.
Wait!
Is this from Onimusha 1?
Or Onimusha 2 village?
Wait, this looks like Onimusha 2's village.
Yeah.
A piece of king really all the way to send forward.
Like, I'll guide you the various destination.
And as such, only functions nearby.
An icon here.
Wait, while exploring.
Why don't you explore it?
Yeah, it looks like Onimush...
Yeah, it looks like the Onimusha 2 town.
A piece of mirror with the power.
As I used to stand for it, like, I'll guide you the various
destinations and they're going to appear.
Alright.
Oh, okay.
It's not too bad.
No demons are here, at least.
Alright, I have to go this way.
What is that thing?
What's happening?
That's fine.
Okay, this way.
I really want to explore, but I'm too- I'll explore later.
Wait, unless...
Yay, dead people!
Oh, this was a hot...
They did not make it.
Is it a hospital?
Alright.
I know it's too big coming back.
I hope nobody's dying right now.
You're just fuel for the gauntlets.
Nice.
Alright.
That's it for the Gema.
did their victim uh are you okay oh my god i did it guys i
saved someone i finally did it you came in the nick of time
i hope this can go some way to repaying you guys i did it
i'm a hero
yeah i have to go this way we did it patrick we saved the
city finally
What?
Oh my god, there's a...
It's walking over there.
It does.
Now imagine if I played with mouse and keyboard.
Gordon ladies got me running all over the damn place.
Shutting these riffs.
Okay, but there is items here.
I'm gonna grab this.
Whoops!
Maybe I should have.
All right, fine.
With the power of Axism!
I never learned.
All right.
I finally saved my first civilian, guys.
All right, now we can go back this way.
Come on, the other dead bodies.
They don't matter.
Wait, what?
Come on.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Wait, headshot does count.
Guys, imagine I played with mouse and keyboard, though.
That's it.
Guys, imagine.
It would have been so easy.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm just thinking about it.
I'm better.
You have to relearn all the Oh, Justin.
Wait, wait.
Okay, let's see.
Let's see.
Actually, I'm curious.
What is...
Okay, what is the arrow?
Control.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, my God.
Just I have an idea.
I have an idea.
Yes, yes, yes.
Alright, let's see.
When using a controller...
Okay, when using a controller...
okay but what if it's not controller what if it's not
controller though wait let me try it okay no that that
that's the controller what's the sensitivity for control for
no guys guys guys guys i have a plan guys it's gonna oh wait
was there camera shake on I didn't even notice.
I hope nobody was getting motion sickness.
There we go.
Let me...
Camera.
Put that at...
Actually, we'll put that at...
4.
That should be good.
Wait, aim camera.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
4.
Okay, I have an idea.
I have an idea.
I...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, actually, I have a
brilliant idea.
Okay, okay, I can figure it out.
I'm cooking here.
I'm cooking.
I'm dual wielding.
What the fuck is that?
No.
Okay, it's not her.
Okay, okay.
I thought it was her.
Okay, I thought it was someone else.
What the fuck?
Oh, okay, they have Kalat.
That's good.
Come on.
Oh, shit, what the fuck?
Okay, we gotta get this guy.
Okay, I gotta get him, though.
Oh, shit!
all right let me suck that's it all right that should be
enough and then suck suck suck okay there we go suck start
sucking all right nice i just have to keep yelling at it and
then it'll start What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
Forgot about this guy.
Alright, you yell at it enough.
I'm sorry.
Fuck, I didn't want this.
Okay, I don't want to use it just in case something happens
to me.
You can use it enhanced equipment.
Oh, there's so many enhancements.
I can't use it yet.
Which is very annoying.
Wait.
Is there anything over here?
Okay, no.
Alright.
Oh, he wants me to go backwards.
What if there's something over here?
Wait, there is something over here.
The shrine!
But are there any items here?
Oh, there is.
I knew it.
There's always something over here.
Alright, let's grab all these items first before we go do
the objective.
What?
Oh, reading time.
So nice of my lady friend to teach me how to read.
It reminds me once if you die.
Oh, I hope...
Ooh.
I hope it doesn't use it.
Wait, is he dead?
Oh, yeah, no, that's a bunch of dead bodies.
Okay, this was my plant watch.
And then...
Small fry.
Oh.
We guys didn't see that.
Sorry, I accidentally flicked.
I accidentally flicked my boat.
Have you tried waking your eyes?
Maybe they're just sleeping on...
God, they're so lazy.
Sleeping on the job?
over there yeah whoa
wait i got an idea oh he started burning wait that's
nice that's fucking right
oh here we go see that is i don't know how i i don't know
what i did But I did it.
Oh, there's treasure, though.
This really is looking bad.
I did it, guys.
I saved the day.
Planned.
Very intentional gameplay there.
But what did you do, Doki?
Very intentional.
I won the game.
That's what I did.
Where is the treasure?
Oh, there it is.
Why are they so British?
They just came back from a semester abroad.
Guys?
All of them.
There was like an exchange program earlier.
There was a big exchange program.
Where they sent a bunch of Japanese villagers and samurai
over to London.
a bunch of their civilians over to feudal japan you know
just simple things like that he's gonna what the fuck okay
that should have hit okay that's bullshit okay there's like
an invisible wall like there's like actually a distance
crawling of gunma there's like a distance that can't all
right there you go there you go I'll always somehow make it
an FPS
game Tokyo always find a way to make it a shooter hey what
all right wait left hand on the controller right hand on
mouse and keyboard I'm dual wielding!
I'm actually dual wielding!
Killing people and playing with a corpse is disgusting.
It's like this is...
Here we go.
This is left hand, I control my right hand on M&K.
I'm cooking.
A new cheat code activate.
I'm actually dual wielding.
Don't worry, I'm activating my aim assist right now too.
All right, here we go.
Why use sword when you have a gun?
I somehow made a samurai game of shooter.
I'm so fucked, guys.
I'm so fucked.
When we're back, when we have to start using our swords,
this ain't gonna be good.
No, it's not.
It's actually easier.
Sorry, I have to...
My phone stopped.
Oh, there it is.
I might actually need to get a new cable.
Am I charging it?
Yeah, okay, I gotta be sure.
There we go.
Alright.
It's muscle memory.
I figured it out, too.
Alright.
I'll make sure there's nothing I'm missing.
Guys, but that's...
Headshots are so satisfying!
Do I need to help them?
Whoops.
Where I got them.
Watch this.
Like, look at that!
It's so satisfying!
So, if you remember to find, dodge, tip, dive, and press the
dodge button.
Thank you for the super chat.
oh my god that one shot it's actually so satisfying hello i
saved the day you're welcome
if it weren't for you i'd be dead here please take this as
thanks yeah um that'll be 500 oh she just gave me one pair
really oh can i just rob you thank you for saving my life i
owe you a I owe you my gratitude.
Here's a pear that I picked out from my tree.
Not even two pears.
One fucking pear.
That's it.
I'm stealing your shit.
You're never coming back here anyway.
Would you want to...
After a demon attack, would you want to come back?
Don't eat there.
Poor.
I see radishes.
celery and cabbages oh but one single pair the 21 ways of
life and 21 ways to bone and rob thank you for the super
chat legend thank you thank you nice this way wait it's not
this way there's a treasure over there I want that treasure
it's like right here it's in that house?
It is.
Oh, it is.
I knew you were holding out.
I knew you were holding out on me.
Oh, you were hiding this little treasure chest.
Oh, your life savings?
God.
Maybe you shouldn't.
Oh, maybe you shouldn't have fucking...
Oh, there's your dead wife, too, by the way.
Maybe you shouldn't...
Maybe you shouldn't have given me just a and this way and
then i had to go left that's right you thought you could
hide your life savings from
me okay there might be stuff here what does it want me to go
it wants me to go this way so i'll go forward so i won't
listen to them what do you mean demons kill i just robbed
them what do you you're not coming back you think they're
gonna come back if a demon invaded your home you're gonna
move back guys think think about it a demon literally killed
your wife and you're gonna fucking move back to move back oh
oh hey this is beautiful
whoa it's a happier time these flowers seem you've gone past
pretty and crossed into bizarre I'm gonna sit my please
please grub this old man just this single morning dragon was
for me my fellow European dragons thank you for the super
chat time thank you thank you what is that are you wishing
for something a spider lilies yeah my loosening it's driven
me mad for years i heard this shrine can sever fates if my
fate is to suffer oh no
i'm no why was it one but okay i'm gonna not hold my
controller how did you get an injury like that i guess i'll
never know his backstory this shrine rid me of that horrible
fate and i've never been You just didn't matter, guys.
He didn't have a fucking name.
We'll never know the knee lore.
I know.
How did you injure your knee?
Did you take an arrow to it?
That just looks like a...
That looks like a demon flower.
Yeah, that's blood.
That's blood.
Yeah, no, that's blood.
Okay, nobody wants to talk to me.
Those look like evil, Plats.
All I want is to spend forever with you.
But with this illness, forever won't be long.
Oh.
Fade brought us together.
I'd give everything to keep it from tearing us apart.
It might be high from the lilies.
Oh.
Is there anybody in there?
Oh, yeah, no.
They're all high.
Oh, yep, 100%.
Never mind.
Oh, yep.
There is a gas leakage somewhere.
I'll save.
100%.
I think there might have been a gas leak.
Okay, where do I go?
The fuck?
How did they just walk past all these demons?
Oh.
They'll just fuel for the gauntlets.
Yes!
Oh, shit.
Bo, I'm full violence!
You know what?
Yeah!
Just because I can.
Ready, worth my time.
Alright.
You got worse my money.
I paid enough for this legend.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dual wielding, dual wielding right now.
That's why 1v1s.
Foes only.
Alright.
Uh, parts or it cannot be entered.
You have to maybe have to purify other areas or to make them
accessible.
Oh, I was just trying to grab the item.
Oh, there's an item behind me.
I'm gonna grab that before I go into like, uh, the dark
zone.
Oh, there's items here too.
Grab all of these first.
Alright, I love, I like the game so far.
I like the gameplay.
This looks like bait.
It's not?
It's not bait?
Oh, they're in there.
Okay, but wait, let me uh...
This is slaughter.
I've seen battlefields once again.
Okay, now!
No!
Oh!
oh my god there you go oh god nice really yeah that's right
yeah do oh that's right take that damn i told you the dual
wield this is it i figured it out guys this is not gonna
work in the boss fight but the Like, other than, I figured
it out in the mobs.
God, there's so many items.
I wish I could use it.
I think that sucks, because I feel like...
Like, I know...
At the moment, I can upgrade to go crazy.
Oh, my God.
This will only work in a...
My fight is that only works when I'm in a tight corridor
where nobody will push me.
Where I can just fight them one by one and I can slowly back
out.
As long as all those conditions is met, I'm gaming.
Oh, I don't like that.
Oh, it's these guys.
I haven't seen them in forever.
Oh my god.
Okay.
All right.
That's fine All right, blade, oh my god, he's letting it rip
Let it rip
Wait, wait unless
Dual wielding
Oh shit
what but you like that it always works why is she so good at
dual wielding
nice all land she's still sleeping should i dunk this thing
in a bucket of water guess i'll go ask takamura what's next
i love my i love my british exchange student samurai what
the i'm just that good guys i'm done it's travel back do i
do a long way okay do i uh i have to go home but i don't
know if i i don't think i've explored i'm gonna explore this
area the water mate
all right let them pray to the devil for
anything to not parry it's not just that guys it's just very
satisfying when you hit the headshot it's not because I
don't want to parry it's just very very satisfying
there is items here I knew exploring was a good idea I had a
feeling too.
Like the sound it makes when you hit it too.
Okay, this way.
Is this something that...
Okay, we all go this way.
I want to see if there's any items here.
Oh, well the gate is...
Oh, it's locked.
There's nothing here.
Wow.
What a mess.
There's no way I can get through here.
Alright.
We clean it up.
So we can go home now.
See, everybody's chill.
Look at that.
I guess living here.
I guess like the property valley, if you're closer to the
fucking Onimusha, like, there's nothing to worry about.
Fuck the people who live far away.
Fuck the...
I guess, like, fuck those guys.
The further you are, the more fucked you are, I guess.
You guys are still, like, chilling, still shopping.
Half the town is fucking dead.
Walking around like there isn't a demon invasion.
Which means you've done well.
You have my gratitude, Masashi.
her up i still haven't heard a word from this thing yeah i
am awake oh thanks i wasn't talking about you i apologize
for the trouble i have caused it shall no longer be an issue
she's away now allow me to tell you everything okay
it's good to see you again shizuka But for an ony of your
standing to be reduced to a soul in a gauntlet, this can
surely mean only one thing.
It is as you suspect.
Hell is now the realm of the Gemma.
I escaped into this gauntlet.
The rest of my people have likely perished.
There are no words for this.
Antony's strong?
How did you get beaten by Gemma?
yeah they were led from hell's depths by a formidable
commander we're undone by his strategies the gilma reside in
the deepest stratum of hell the only brilliant strategist
you'll find down there is the one we imprisoned there a man
named minamoto no yoshitsune yoshitsune the hero yoshitsune
there's nobody who doesn't know that name who He's me.
Guys, I don't know.
But I think he might be my spirit animal.
I think Musashi...
He's my spirit animal.
He's me.
Who?
Everybody knows him?
Who the fuck's that guy?
Why is he giving out gauntlets?
Why to me?
Yeah, why is he mass producing gauntlets?
It doesn't make me special anymore.
without reason.
Omega love.
He's literally me.
Brother from another mother.
Also, Yoshitsune is doing.
Sounds like I have to purify another temple or something.
If he gets this thing off me, I'll do it.
You have my thanks, Musashi.
Hey, you're Shizuka, as in Shizuka Gozen, right?
Doesn't that make Yoshitsune your...
You're what?
That story's in the past.
I don't know feudal Japan history, please.
Tell me.
You'll hear it sooner or later.
I'm...
I'm musubi.
I'm literally musubishi right now.
I'm literally musubishi.
Like, what do you mean?
Just leave me on a cliffhanger?
Why are you fake posting?
Yeah, damn.
Yeah, damn fake posting.
on the workings of the gondola let us speak beside the
spirit maker when's it supposed to be my turn from FGO
why are they all vague posting do they not want me to save
the world
scared of saying something vague girl I already know how to
use these things that's how we got to Kiyomizudera temple it
has other uses.
Have it resonate with the Gema souls you've absorbed, and it
can draw out even more of the gauntlet's power.
Resonate?
Seeing is knowing, Miss Ashi.
First, just try touching the spirit mirror.
Alright, I'll touch it.
Okay, I'll upgrade now.
Oops.
Yay!
Can improve stats such as health and power.
quiet front depend on the equipment type check now enhancing
item improve your stats okay do I have to oh I have to max
improve to improve proficient earn a major stat boost R&B to
change your basic skills oh what this is new there's a skill
tree now looking at a search for Poa no no there's a reason
why we don't have eye trackers I'm crying for it has but
depending on the skill type hold on what's this deflect oh
there we go
okay there's what are you serious how many I feel like
there's 20 different ways to block are you oh my oh my god
this is going to be so bad for me now I have to press a just
before being So not only do I have a parry deflect, I have a
a parry block, I have a parry deflect that at the time, and
I have a dodge block, and then I have, oh my god, oh,
remember the 10 T's.
Oh, holy shit.
Oh, this is not going to be good.
Now I'm going to want to be good.
All right, let's see it.
Increase the power.
Needs stealth.
Reflex.
Performing a will.
When engaged, will pressing exit for four.
Okay.
I feel like that's good.
What's this?
Oh.
Okay, I just want to make sure I have everything.
Only vision making breakable by parts and easier to spot.
Enhances making hidden treasures.
Okay, we don't need that.
Two Celestials.
Uh...
Are you serious?
Was it Dance Dance Revolution?
Oh my god!
Okay.
Oh my god, that's a fucking rhythm game.
Oh, it always has been.
Oh, okay.
Oh, my God.
All right, we'll enhance that.
The combat system is very...
Very intimidating, I will say.
It's an FPS and a rhythm game.
Okay, I feel like...
Oh my God.
okay just i oh my god how many i can't guys at some point we
might just have like like back to back fucking back to back
guys next week might just i'm sorry next week might just be
a onimusha week because there is no way i can remember all
of this next week potentially might be like 80 percent
onimusha i will all of this there is no way and at the
present oh my god
okay i can't unlock this yet thank god i i don't know if i'm
ready i don't know if i'm ready i'll just unlock this
I'm like reading this I'm like what do you mean fuck it
just upgrade everything I have
the 20 ways of doing your strength is increased I already
forgot oh my god okay I just got pressed stuff at the right
time He's literally a pile of meat stapled together, like I
said.
Like, without the gauntlet, he would just be a pile of meat
on the floor.
Like it or not, if you want to get rid of that gauntlet,
you'll have to kill Genma.
And if you want to kill Genma, the most efficient way is to
master the gauntlet.
Who better to learn from than yours truly?
My waifu?
You.
Me.
Who else could teach you to fight with Oni powers?
When you're ready, ring the bell in the temple grounds.
Ring the bell and then what?
It's not going to suck me in like that damn well, is it?
Oh no, is it like a training ground thing?
No, but close enough, I suppose.
It won't kill you in any case.
okay all right it's time to ring the bell let me save oh my
god what did i upgrade again oh my god a rector thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you guys i need to catch
up on this vod asap just we're gonna see you're still going
how's the new only moosh have been so far it's been really
fun it's just there's so there is the 20 ways of blocking
the 20 ways of deflecting oh my god okay all right
and the god pressing x to perform okay press x after
performing a six vessel oh my god what okay all right yeah
look at this real quick i need to look at
all right give me a sec i need to like look at everything i
bought okay all right This I have to deflect it at the right
time.
And then...
Okay, I don't need to do...
I don't have to worry about this yet.
I don't have to worry about this.
I just need to...
Wait, what did I buy?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, it's...
It's the deflect.
Okay, it's the deflect.
I don't know if I should upgrade this now.
Because I'm worried...
Should I save?
I feel like I should save it.
I didn't pay $90 to block...
I don't I feel like I should save because I don't want this
to be my only charm all right it's time to ring the bell I
feel like I'm still in a tutorial too I don't think I'm like
in the main game yet this all feels tutorial like like
for three hours deep and I feel like I'm still in tutorial
all
right I'm here sensei what do you want to teach me Is it all
right for you to leave the temple like this?
It's fine.
Time doesn't pass in the living world while we're in here.
I dropped out of blocking school.
Forget it.
How the fuck do you even do aggressive style?
I feel like anyone that chose aggressive style is a fucking
masochist.
I've even got some rewards for you when you succeed.
Oh, it's like a hyperbolic chamber.
yeah oh yeah it's like training where i get extra rewards
say no to that let's get started all right oh my god i'm
actually laughing all right oh yeah you're gonna learn to
deflect all right let's try let's get started okay
Oh shit.
My phone.
I actually do need to buy a new...
Oh, give me a sec guys.
My phone is no longer charging effectively.
So I might have to grab a new cable.
Or my battery on my old phone this time.
We'll see how it goes.
Alright.
Just before being hit.
Okay.
Alright.
Whoops.
I fucked it up.
Okay.
Alright, there we go.
Okay, it's not as hard as as the other stuff, but it's still
not ideal.
Alright.
I'm labbing right now.
Alright, wait, wait.
This is easy.
Wait, this is not too hard.
This is not too hard.
It's very forgiving.
Oh my god, it's very forgiving.
Oh, wait.
He just started kicking him out.
It is actually guys.
It's actually the most forgiving one.
I see the vision.
I see it guys.
I see it See it Why?
Why would I do that to myself?
Defeat them all too.
Oh new outfit You want to learn more about fighting you know
the place Also, this is for you.
Thank you.
Thank you Fear not that Doki has practiced 10,000 blocks,
but the fear that Doki has practiced one block 10,000 times.
But the trip, though, can't prove you're a better man, Doki.
Oh, it's a whirlwind.
Oh, wait.
Oh, shit.
RB when they only gauge.
Oh, this is it.
Near flame to ignite the whirlwind.
Uh...
Nye.
What is this?
A weapon created by the Oni.
It's not your first time seeing...
It's the spinning wheel.
Spinning.
It's in the other Onimushas.
Yes.
And there should be other Oni weapons scattered around Kyoto
as well.
If you're already running about killing Genma, why not
search for them?
You can never have too many weapons.
That's true.
Does that make him use all of them in the same fight?
Press RB when...
Oh, I can.
I can swap.
Wait, that's so good for me.
I can actually swap weapons.
Okay, I want to...
Wait, talk to me.
I want to fight him!
That's it.
I'm going back in.
He thinks I'll leave.
I'm going back.
I'm going back in.
I'm going to kill him.
I'm going to show him.
Try and filter me.
So, where to next?
I sense an unusual Gema presence in the nearby area.
I'm going to laugh.
Let us hunt it out.
An unusual Gema.
Where is it?
Oh.
Clarence on again?
Alright, let's check the story progress or set it as a
destination.
Oh, these are all just...
Oh.
I was hoping you'd say we'd have time for a break.
Well, I got another... I should be able to upgrade then.
Alright, I'm going back in.
That's it.
I'm gonna get a sick new outfit.
I ain't no quitter.
I've been labbing!
That's fucking right!
Actually, is there another?
Oh, I can have all of these.
Okay.
Let's see.
Select.
I'm ready.
Bring it on.
Bring the fuck on!
Watch this.
Right where we left off.
Wait, what?
I wish we'd stop you at least.
Where's that?
That's right!
Is that your bet?
You thought that would cut through?
Too bad.
Who the hell wears a metal hat?
Okay, wait.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Nicely done.
Wait!
Ah, shit!
Oh, shit!
No, shit!
That's right.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
It's okay.
Ah, he's been lying to you.
You're so damn weak, you fraud.
Okay.
What?
Locked your nerve?
Scared?
All right, there we go.
Oh, my God.
This is cheating.
Oh, he was also laughing.
He was also laughing.
Time to finish you off.
That's right.
Get out of here.
I'm a better master than you.
That's right.
I can mash harder.
That's, yes, yes.
This is what I wanted.
What I needed.
This dance with death.
I forgot about that.
I forgot.
Does that hurt?
Okay.
No.
Wait.
Okay, okay.
I'm going to try the thing I learned.
Does it reflect I learned?
Right where we left off.
Death can't stop us.
I wish it would stop you at least.
Okay.
I did it.
I'm just getting started, God, you.
Okay, wait, wait.
Oh, my God, I didn't do it.
I don't know how to do it!
I'm trying!
Okay, wait, wait, I'll try again.
Alright, come on.
Oh, he's just...
Okay.
There we go.
There's no...
Okay.
Oh
You bitch You look terrible, Masashi That's it That's all
you've got I'm trying to do the fucking crazy block I
thought Right where we left off Death can't stop us I wish
it was so cool though that looked so cool until i couldn't
do it properly watch this it was worth it it was so worth it
though what could be more fun than dancing with death all
right here we go oh that's right put your back in
oh what okay that was a dodge you bitch all right there we
go we got him slash him what a thrill what a riot mom is
that he There we go.
You stupid bastards!
Oh, I...
That's fucking...
No!
No, you bitch!
Okay.
Fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
So filthy.
Here we go.
Got you!
No!
Woo!
Swing!
Follow me!
Oh my god, you fucker.
No!
Yes!
I locked in.
This is bullshit!
No!
There we go.
We did it.
See you guys, I told you I labbed.
I told you.
I hate that fucking.
I thought I did it.
Oh my god, where's my cool new outfit?
Where's my sick new clothes?
Hello?
Where's my...
Where's my sick new clothes?
Where is it?
Oh, I may...
Maybe I'll get it.
Okay, wait.
Maybe he has sick clothes, too.
Maybe he...
Now I can ache.
Let's see.
Alright.
Oh my god, I don't want to be behind him.
Oh my god.
Oh, just stay behind him.
Oh, he doesn't know!
Oh, what?
Okay, that's bullshit.
There we go.
It's fine.
There's nothing to ram the sock.
Wait, there is.
Oh my god.
There we go.
No!
It's okay.
I'm okay.
Just a flesh wound.
Okay, watch this though.
So good.
I could eat on the old day.
Oh my god!
Dual wielding!
The power of dual wields!
Oh my god!
That's right!
With the power of dual wields!
Holy shit!
Okay.
Well, that was...
Oh my god.
that was actually an accident.
Oh.
Okay.
That's good.
I need to grab this though before.
Alright.
He still has his helmet, so...
Oh, shit.
There we go.
Oh, fuck.
What?
I didn't dodge that?
Alright.
I need it.
Actually, we need to go.
Alright, it's fine.
Oh, my God.
I try to roll.
There we go.
We got hit.
Kalash, he's doing this.
I don't know.
He's drawing power from the souls too.
Do I?
No, I...
That hits me!
That hits me again!
No!
Okay, there we go.
Well, that keeps okay.
I've got it, guys.
I'm too cocky right now.
Unless
No, no
Come on.
Yes, oh first try first try Oh my god first try all right oh
i just wanted i i wanted to replicate the high i got from
the first one i guys i just wanted to replicate that parry
that sick ass parry i got all right glad we're just getting
here thank god he thinks this is beneath me i'm glad he also
knows that this is beneath me
all right it's good to know you're gonna fuck it oh get out
of here they got scared you mean nothing to me all right
we're just doing this for extra items so I can upgrade all
right blocking i'm so i'm so good at that all right here we
go we all know how good i am at this
but all right can i kill them now oh no don't do this to me
don't do this to me all right Oh my god.
Stop!
All right, there we go.
There we go.
There's this guy up.
Okay.
God damn it!
I'm trying, I swear!
Sensei, I'm trying!
Oh shit, I didn't realize that we're doing this again.
I mean, I'm going to execute this guy.
Surely he won't be imported, right?
Alright.
There we go.
Get him out of here.
Oh, I didn't do that before.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, shit.
No, don't make me do this.
Okay, evading.
I can do evades.
We all learn that I can do evades.
All right, watch this.
All right.
Okay, he's got...
To be fair, his wind up...
I thought he would wind up more.
Knock it.
There we go.
We can do that.
Ten years of blocking.
What else do you want me to do, Sensei?
Oh, no.
okay this one there you go there you go thank God he only
wants me to do it twice all right we execute him who's next
who's next who's next no okay round two round two all right
there we go all right now i just have to kill you
oh my god i hate blocking so much exhaustion that's me right
now you're dead what am i doing not only will pairing open
up opportunities it will also field okay
did i do it Okay, there you go.
All right.
This should make him exhausted now.
Easy.
All right.
We're doing it.
We're doing, we're speed running now.
I stopped the blade.
Let's get started.
Oh.
This is the hard one though.
Don't worry, I can do this.
God!
I don't understand!
Oh my god, this is torture!
Okay.
Alright.
Let me fight it, fight back.
The window is so tight!
Let's get started.
I swear to God!
Oh my god, there we go.
There we go.
I'm Ultra Instinct.
Right now.
Ultra Instinct!
Okay.
Starting now.
Here we go.
My god, why is it so hard?
I don't understand!
Fuck you.
I'm just, I'm executing him.
I don't care.
Just fuck you in general.
Alright, you.
I should...
You did not that simple!
I... Okay, it's fine.
I did it.
It's fine.
I don't care.
Just sublime, boy.
Is the e-cent?
I don't know.
The e-cent fucks with me so hard.
Let's get started.
I don't know what to do.
What the fuck?
Blade lock me, bitch.
Blade lock me!
Oh my god, whatever.
Oh my god.
Oh my.
Oh, now I get the E-San.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh, I hate you.
I hate you so much.
Just fucking Strike your sword
Oh my god Fucking course you don't do Oh my god
Okay Come on Come on Do your stupid blade lock Oh my god
There we go There we go
You can never win a blade lock if you...
If you never blade lock.
It's just that easy.
I hate you.
I hate you so much.
No, no, no.
You do not get the satisfaction.
No!
He might actually get the satisfaction!
Oh my god!
Oh no, you fucking spiked back, you whore!
I swear to God you better die!
Don't get over it for itself!
It's illegal!
all right there you go there's fine okay now we're blade
barrage oh my god
oh my god i hate you there you go there you go he did it now
we just got kill him
get out of here
Yeah, just shoot it!
Alright.
We did it.
We're almost done with our hyperbolic time chamber.
Get two Celestials.
What is this?
Oh, is that the... Oh, that's the HP.
Let's get started.
Alright, I did it.
Oh, why is this tutorial like the easiest shit ever?
And they made me go through hell.
That's it.
your heart out okay we did it we did it we're doing it all
right oh yeah after what i was going through earlier
all right the thing that sucks though is that my power-ups
do not it like overlaps with my other stuff too which i
think is is shitty because like um in the first odmushes uh
you're if you use one of the special weapon abilities it
doesn't use up the other special weapon abilities so you can
combo it over and over again and that's the only thing i
wish uh stay the same like one i guess not the only like one
of the things i wish stay the same so i can combo all the
items together I want to use I noticed that I noticed this
when um I used it and the my the blue my power for the other
one was gone then you removed my cheese my cheese my
beautiful cheese do I have like enough to upgrade something
or no Because I got a lot of items.
I just don't know.
Yeah, I did.
I like cheesing.
Okay.
At least I have more stuff now.
Alright.
What did they give me?
Nothing!
They said I could change my appearance!
I killed them for nothing?
Okay.
Congratulations, Toki.
You got nothing.
I got scabbed?
Where is my drip?
What was the point?
I'm beating him up!
Oh, all bosses.
Are you fucking kidding me?
All bosses.
Alright.
Use it to check abilities?
Oh, just to be like what I have.
You're saving it for Onimusha 6.
Do not worry.
I'm doing this first.
What the fuck?
Oh, I can't do this first.
I have to do this first.
Oh, wait.
I just realized.
That's a pig.
Alright.
Dual wield.
W dual wield.
Oh, she seems...
Not...
scared of what's going on.
on nonchalant oh she's blind i mean blind but not death
hello sir i can tell your boundary she not here like she
seems very calm for what's going on you rage against that
which blocks your path i don't need sight to see that it's
the armor on your right hand that's not where i am Ma'am,
you pour into that air.
Oh, please don't be escorted.
I'm too bound still to a terrible fate, if not for its
blessing.
And there surely is bliss.
It's a blessing.
Surely you can tell.
I couldn't help but compare my looks to everyone I saw.
And it distressed me so.
But I suffer no longer.
Oh.
You can't be serious.
Took her eyes out on purpose?
Just because she thinks she's ugly?
This shrine is set to grind the binding and severing up
fates to its pilgrims.
Oh, it's a gas leak shrine.
But the malice has messed it up.
It's like you're hearing the gas leak season.
They'd take my arm as well.
Would that suit you?
I think she got a little too high.
Like hell it would.
Let's purify this place and put an end to it.
see how do i get there it's right there careful what you
wish for and then what's the other one oh i can get two
bridges and one stone
all right is that a demon oh they all came back that's fine
i feel like i got all the items though so it doesn't really
matter okay there's an invisible wall there is no way that
doesn't hit There you go.
There we go.
There was an invisible wall there.
That was one-sided.
Ain't no shit.
Alright.
Time to go to the...
The gas leak.
Oh, oh what?
Her legs gone.
Oh dear.
That frown won't do.
He took away his leg.
troubling you boy nothing that could dampen your mood i bet
10 years i suffered from the pain in my knee the curse has
been lifted i mean you got your wish then okay right you are
i prayed to be severed from that fate and look i mean i
guess such a wise god i guess amputation is a solution it
off.
Guys, my hand hurts.
Let me just cut my hand up.
No leg, no pain.
It works.
True.
I must say, I cannot make any sense of this.
Can't have knee pain if no knee.
Only a genius would think of throwing away a leg to cure
knee pain.
My back aches too.
I just cut the entire car.
Oh.
Guys, this ghastly might feel a bit too intense, guys.
This, some ghastly might be too much.
I think it's corroding the cells.
What's this?
It might be corroding the brain cells right now.
Dolls feels ominous.
And twins.
Maybe I'm overthinking it.
Your instincts are correct, Misashi.
There are souls trapped inside these dolls.
It's the couple.
Even if it costs them their entire bodies.
Are you two really all right with this?
Oh, it's the couple.
That's seeing how...
Oh, I mean, at least they're together forever.
I think that's...
I think that's all right.
I mean, it's that...
They're not hurting anyone.
I mean, I hope they don't have kids.
That would be a great help.
We don't have kids, but they're not hurting anyone.
I mean, this one?
Oh my god, my thing is confused now.
This is a Shrug.
Oh, this Shrug.
Yorima, sir.
Ring any bells?
He was an Oni.
He was known as a hero for his deeds in the mortal realm.
But he eventually met his hand in battle.
Well, his soul here, I would have begged his aid, but...
Well, we did come on a nest.
We've no other options then.
Let us call upon the eight stout pillars.
There are a group of eight statues imbued with formidable
strength.
They should be somewhere within the shrine.
Huh?
It's better not take much longer.
I'm starting to lose my mind as well.
But it goes through... Oh, I can't go through here.
Here?
Okay.
Greetings, Arnie Warrior.
We are known as the Eight Stout Pillars.
That's an odd name for a group of five.
Where's the rest of them?
Where's the rest of you?
He snuck it.
Thank Enmus Fault, the one who has taken over the shrine.
He tricked humans with malice and had them take our
brothers.
They made off with our eldest, third and seventh kin.
like me bring your brothers back will you lend us your power
he's me real he's just like me i can feel their presence and
not far from here i shall guide you all right can't be too
hard
okay Oh, locked gate.
Well, I've already, like, been there.
I guess because they all spawned back, so...
Also, they cut his leg that far.
I was gone for, like, an hour.
We've, like, catarized that.
Alright, it's time.
You're just fuel for the coolant.
Alright.
Oh.
Wait, it's all head.
How do I headshot?
There we go.
Okay, I have to use knives too.
Wait.
It's faster to...
It might actually be faster to use bow.
Alright.
One of the apes down to pillars is nearby.
Can you find him?
I'm actually impressed that that old man did not die of
blood loss.
Oh, I'm gonna grab this.
Alright, here he is.
Wait.
I'm down from there?
Where?
Oh, here.
I think you conveniently placed ladder.
Alright, number seven.
Fine and gentle sword.
It's a little catarizing.
Yeah.
Okay, and then the next here.
Wow!
I mean, thank God.
I was, like, wondering how to...
It's not a headshot?
Alright, come on.
That should have been a headshot.
It just...
I'm just pre-firing, just in case.
Alright.
Someone's gonna show up here.
all right come on knock knock do a wielding right now come
on okay nice there no nobody there
oh oh oh oh oh it's okay he doesn't know he doesn't hear
that i just wanted to shoot from the ladder There you go.
Easy.
Huh?
Well, I have to start crawling on my knees.
Oh, I'm proning.
Oh, this feels so trapped like...
Oh my god.
Oh, this feels like a trap, but alright.
There's someone there!
Just keep coming.
Alright, there you go.
Really?
Okay, we're fine.
Piss off.
There we go.
Easy.
I'm glad they always wait.
They always wait for me.
All right, one of the stone pillars, number one.
You're so glad you came.
Not being able to get around on your own must be tough.
have been afraid we'd lend you our power he wasn't just
playing hiding us away bought him time time for what clever
for again man I guess for more for more knees don't take him
lightly all right open open oh oh I thought a would like Do
an auto open at this time.
I have to slash my own locks.
Oh my god, play for myself.
Why is my video game not playing for me?
Alright.
Yeah, it's the blind crazy girl.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, like they're blocking me from somewhere.
Okay, the issue is that there is a block.
Oh my god, tank block.
This is...
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Wait, actually, fuck this guy first.
Alright.
Oh my god.
It's like he has a helmet that blocks headshots!
It's not fair!
Here we go.
Okay.
It's left side.
Oh, I can't go this way.
Why is a demon wearing a helmet?
Bro, guns- oh, because of arrows.
Guns haven't even been invented yet.
That's- yeah.
Who wears a metal helmet?
Are fucking cheaters.
Oh shit.
Okay, I should actually save them so I can get free shit.
Yeah, there you go.
There you go.
You're so lucky.
You're glad I like money.
I owe you my life.
If it pleases you, take...
I'm a hero.
I'm a hero for hire.
They could die.
Another pair.
All right.
What the fuck am I gonna do with a pair?
This better be the fucking...
I should just let them die.
I should...
What the fuck am I gonna do with a pair?
You firing?
What a mess.
Oh, no thing.
Sends again the presence.
Be ready for anything.
Aw, man.
Where could they...
Where could the thing be?
man where are i going is your conveniently placed ladder
where is my conveniently placed ladder oh it's here
conveniently placed door
all right now i've actually fight
i there should be collab though i think that i think it
would be cooler this game has collab not
There you go.
No.
What happened?
Why no?
I killed them all.
What?
Did someone die?
I'm pretty sure this pile of bodies is already dead.
Nice.
I'm pretty sure the pile of bodies were there already guys.
There you go.
Dasling beautiful soil.
Did you ever keep me waiting?
To think they would leave me!
The most beautiful of us brothers in such a place.
So humble.
Well, tardy or not, it's thanks to you I can return to my
brothers.
I appreciate it.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh.
carry me a chip on my face would be a dying loss to the
beauty of this world i hope i dropped him on his head right
we should be able to restore the pillar's power now let's
return them to all right let's go back he's a narcissist
throw him out guys all rock lives matter
all right let's see all right now we go back
I have a feeling it's gonna be a boss fight.
Because he did say there was like a...
Biting time with the demon stuff.
With the hiding the rocks.
I can feel the boss fight.
Oh my god, I thought I could parry that.
I wanted to be cool.
I want to be so cool!
Oh!
okay that was cool though wasn't that i mean well done that
was cool though you know what wait that's it it was still
pretty cool there's stuff here yeah okay um something feels
off what a terrifying presence oh no that must be a
dangerous game what did he cut this tab we'll lend you a
power worthy of the kind this are you serious come on throw
the needle ah i don't think you noticed though what okay
my baby
there you go that's fucking right that's right oh fuck
that's no longer right no
oh my god okay that's okay all right that's aura farming
that was aura farming right there that's My wife baited me,
but I still managed to aura farm.
My...
She baited me, but I still managed to aura farm.
That's all that matters.
She might have baited me.
She said beware.
Oh, wait, I could have just exploded that.
All right.
Nice treasure.
Hey, can you ask?
Oh, my God, it's lore.
All I got was lore.
Oh, thank God.
Sword updates, though.
I'll take that.
All right.
Oh, nice.
Okay, I got a lot of upgrade stuff, which is good.
All right.
I'm going to go this way.
I've been joining this game a lot.
Again, you shout out to MSI for today's sponsor.
For sponsoring this game.
It's been really fun.
If you guys have been joining, I will be giving away five
game codes at the end of the stream.
Alright, so...
Oh, wait, more.
I swear to God, if I...
Alright.
Here we go.
But this game has been really fun.
All right, I guess who lives here?
All right, I'm ready for another pair.
Give me your pair.
I guess that was the wife.
That the husband left.
That the samurai, you saved me, didn't you?
Please, accept this as my thanks.
Please check out, click on the link pinned in the chat and
in the description.
I'm excited for another pair.
Oh, we all pr...
Wow!
Man, it's not like I could pick that up right now on a tree.
One whole persimmon.
Wow!
What does this persimmon do anyway?
Oh, golly, gee, an entire persimmon?
All right.
What a twist.
I can finally make a fruit salad.
No, they're not even heals.
It's to upgrade my charms.
Don't talk to blind.
I cast away my vision so that I'd never be tempted.
Alright.
Yeah, they're here to enhance charms.
That's what I was saying.
I was like thinking like...
Alright.
Oh.
Oh, there's no one here anymore.
Ooh.
Huh.
Where are all the people?
Where did they all go?
That's weird.
They're all gone.
Even the creepy dolls are gone.
Oh no, they're still here.
At least they're together forever.
It's not a good set.
Let me look into this when it's not...
Nope.
Alright.
I was just wondering if there's like dead bodies there.
Hero, please take the bears.
Alright.
Let's put him all in.
My brothers.
Can't feel pain.
Or we're right.
I'm not allowed.
You have my thanks, Miyamoto Musashi.
I'll sort the rest of this place out as well.
I hope they didn't cut themselves.
Our power is yours.
We've condensed the malice in the area into a dark mass.
With that, you should be able to glean where that Genma is
and what it's planning.
I was hoping for something a bit more destructive.
Manus, Masashi.
It's all we can muster for now.
Purify this place, however.
Can't have no...
That's true.
Can't have life problems and no life.
It has been a really fun game.
I'm enjoying it a lot.
And don't let the malice swallow you up.
Alright.
Nice.
That's dark as my soul.
Once the purification is complete.
Oh!
Okay, sorry.
It's like, what's that?
Oh, maybe I shouldn't have taken...
Maybe I should not have patched the gas leak, guys.
Uh, no.
As someone for DLSS off.
As someone for brothers, I cannot think anything more awful
than crowded so covered with them love thank you for the
super chat thank y'all oh that seems it's something spooky
oh i mean suck
now where am i joining or severing which do you want then i
was i made to practice a shamisen every day And the mistress
scolds me awfully when I play them wrong.
Or is this the one who cut her fingers?
Oh, in that case, let's sever your teeth with those fingers.
Just say no.
No fingers, no practice.
Or, like, stop playing.
Come, let's have him off.
is key.
Have you ever thought about talking to them?
Oh, well, just, yeah, no, that's easier, I guess.
That's easier.
Now, I'll never have to play that horrible thing again.
Yay!
Finally, the solution to all our problems.
Such lovely fingers.
To I tried everything.
What should I do?
I hate playing this instrument.
Yes, they won't go to waste.
Should I just cut my fingers out?
Poor little humans.
One whiff of malice, and they flock here to donate this and
that.
Great news for the boss.
Oh, no, he's getting consumed by the mammoths.
I suppose you're here about that gauntlet.
Easy enough.
No armed up.
True!
The sashi!
Oh, shit.
Wait!
I think you picked me.
Oh, shit.
He's like from the My Hero Academia.
Why?
Wait, it's the guy from My Hero Academia.
academia Holy shit Not gonna lie This character design is
sick as hell Shit from me Come, let's bind you to a fitting
fate Oh my god Door wheeling, door wheeling time, door
wheeling He draws power from last around him Oh shit
How do I cut it?
Oh.
Jesus Christ!
Silly humans!
How did you figure it out?
What do you mean how?
How did you see the giant thing on my connected to my body?
Get your own talk.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Okay, I don't know what you're fucking...
I don't know what your moves do!
Oh my god.
Yep.
What the fuck?
Jesus Christ!
You're not but spare parts.
Oh my god Fates be bound by my will End the binding you just
don't learn.
Oh my god Your fate is sealed Stop
I'm trying to cut it.
I can't cut it.
I couldn't cut it it oh this guy's hard I didn't know his
patterns I'm trying to figure out how to let's bind you to a
fitting fate are you kidding me I'm trying okay his body
blocking I could free you from that code Oh my god, he's
actually body-blocking me.
He's actually body-blocking me.
Oh my god, this is over.
Get this me out of here.
Get me out.
Just slash, slash me.
Slash me.
Oh my god, stop pro-lying this.
The fun was just getting started too.
He's just, he's fucking body-blocking it.
Come, let's find you to a fitting fate.
Let me know if I can cut it with my bow.
I'm just wondering.
Oh my god, I can't.
The door's power from our surroundings by those friends.
We must sever the connection.
There you go.
Okay, I figured it out.
Now that I know.
Now that I know!
Oh my god, you're a little backslash, bitch!
Okay, I'm just gonna use that then.
from that cursed head gauntlet in an instant why refuse my
kindness your kindness would cost me an arm I'm killing
monsters like keep my limbs attached damn it oh my god
that's where I can combo
page one seven found once more again the binder you just
don't learn no no no no yes it's fine impressive for a
walking stack of spare parts to still live after such a blow
Oh my god.
And yeah.
Oh god.
He's won, he's won!
I don't care if you're binding!
He's grown much stronger.
Be careful.
What?
Can you feel the fear?
How did you figure it out?
Not laughing now.
What do you mean?
Okay,
okay, okay.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
Alright, there we go.
there you go no shit okay there you go are you kidding me
something
for you what what okay that's bad I was I will cut it all up
this doesn't look good No, it doesn't.
Oh.
Clean it off.
Oh my god!
No!
Oh.
Okay.
No!
No, no, no, no!
Okay!
I got another variant!
oh god don't yes you sick games end here
how many faces you have sure i can do something about the
gauntlets would you just die
try it
things to do i'll save dying for another time get back here
you crazy bastard there's no way i can't there's no way oh
my god i swear to god he got in yasha i
Bro, bro use time and I'm like, what...
Who's her?
Who's she?
I had need to test your strength.
Do you understand?
Bro, you fucking kill steal.
I deem you worthy of my will and entrust it to you.
The strength of the eight stout pillars is yours to wield.
Oh, nice.
Bro, this game is hard.
This game is fucking hard.
Like, I'm literally getting carried by my reflexes right
now.
Holy shit, never skip arm day.
Oh, you're not, guys.
I swear to God, you're not steroids, guys.
That's just the next warning I showed up, guys.
I definitely did not take steroids.
They're all natural.
It feels like it could pick up a castle.
For a temple.
The pillar's name was not misplaced.
This will be of great aid to us.
It's like...
Okay, oh, oh, I can finally open the malice stuff.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Granting various exchange for red souls to still visit.
Grant various extra items.
I guess, like, upgrade items?
Can I get upgrade items now?
Okay.
I may be unable to set foot beyond this shrine, but rest
assured I will trade in every way I can You will bring me
genma souls.
I shall take them and bestow you in turn with useful items I
anticipated your visit, Musashi God, he sounds like such a
know it all sounds like such a fucking nerd Oh, he's like
these?
I don't think I need any of this.
I'm gonna use hands yeah so okay it sounds like wait let's
grab that i got a new elf unlocked homie's like i'm actually
i'm gonna use the bathroom real quick guys and also get more
water i'll bear back
yeah i'm having so much fun uh juke aphelia minsel mike and
solid thank you super chat thank you thank you i can't like
it's like i don't there's a word for it like It's, you know
how, like, it's like they do the most, you're about, they do
the most ridiculous thing and you just stun lock.
Like, did that guy just do that?
And he just runs away.
It's so campy.
I, I fucking love it.
Like, I was just like, what the fuck?
Like, what are you going to do now, huh?
You're never going to expect this move.
And I did it.
I didn't expect it.
Nice.
I think it's a fun game so far.
It's hard.
This game is really hard for me.
It'd be fine if I could have a damn break now and then.
It's a hard game, I will say.
I'm literally getting carried right now by my reflexes.
I think it's also because I'm not very good at blocking.
I'm not a good blocker, but I'm enjoying the game.
I'm going to do Yellow Souls.
This has been coming in clutch for me.
What?
Oh.
Yeah.
It's just, it's a very difficult, it's a very difficult
game.
Like, it's just for me in general, this is difficult to
play.
because i'm very bad at blocking but this game you have to
block that's the thing like it punishes you if you don't
block next oh my god i don't know okay we're not getting the
east end we might as well do this we're we're not we're not
getting oh my god i don't feel like we should get east and
we're not getting that i
mean i'd rather get this Because at least I'm...
At least I'm parrying.
I'm...
At least I'm...
You know, at least I'm parrying, guys.
It's like...
I'm so bad at the timing for that.
I'm just terrible at the timing for Isen.
I don't trust myself.
Okay.
We opened that.
So now we have to go to...
Oh, I'm surprised at that.
He had three fucking phases.
That's so bullshit, too.
The fact that he had three phases.
Like, what the fuck?
I have four eels.
What the fuck am I gonna do?
Am I supposed to save him?
Oh, yeah.
I can't wait to get my pears.
Can I kill him after?
You have dispatched all of a Gemma.
Is that victim?
You came in the nick of time.
I hope this can go some way to repaying you.
Can't wait for my pear.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I don't hear.
Whatever.
I mean, it's more than one bean.
at least it's more than one I'll take it guys it was more
than one bean yeah I killed him so that monster was playing
us all for fools being bewitched is no excuse what a stupid
thing I've done to myself yeah you can't see anymore what
will we do now yeah now that you're blind forever the
priests at the shrine here are so kind they've said they'll
find work for all the monsters victims apparently i'm to be
trained as a shrine maiden oh that's sweet it seems you've
been bound to find fate after all not bad also that guy the
guy saved looked rich as hell how rude of me not to notice
oh oh yeah my way no yeah
Welcome visit again once you've oh she didn't deny it she
didn't deny it explain then we're in guys Oh my god, I do
love a mystery Our what I all into it She didn't say no
We're so in It's this way Oh What
Whoops.
Well, I guess I should have done that.
Wait, I actually don't want to try that.
Oh, it's not as rewarding.
Alright.
I'll suck the slows out, and then...
Boom.
Alright.
Oh, there's so many controls.
Guys, I have to remember.
YB?
I had to remember what?
IB does particularly bad in this area the malice is
positively overflowing marriage prayer dream time to put the
pillars power to work again all right now you remember to
break she does any press YB I think that's like my other
creeps there's so many controls I have to remember
it's a lot it really is a lot
up it looks to be a plant that releases malice oh that's a
shoot-it great volume if left alone it will do untold damage
to this area nothing for it it's our season godly i guess i
shoot it right yeah why can't all combos be x or iv uh cut
it down why can't i just oh i do have to cut it down all
right um let me figure gotta go why
okay fuck okay the wounds that ended your life are being
sealed by the only gauntlet amidst such powerful malice you
can only do so for so long that makes things harder oh i
don't like this mechanic oh welcome back poison swaps
welcome back ah yes oh shit
Welcome back, Poison Swamps!
It's like we never left.
All I have to do is cut down this ugly plant and clear the
nose.
Time's up, plant.
The Mali Suspend.
I feel like Japanese games love Poison Swamps.
I don't know why.
I feel like it's just a huge pattern when it comes to...
games made uh made in japan they just love poison oh my god
you fucking kidding me there you go well done yeah americans
love that's true americans love uh water levels and then
oh my gosh oh nice you're nothing Wait, can I just...
Shoot for Lohan?
What's he gonna do?
Impressive bow technique.
What's he gonna... Is he okay?
The Miyazaki special.
Oh, hey.
America's love water levels and Japanese love poison.
I'm gonna be lost here for sure.
Okay, it doesn't tell me where to go anymore.
I'm just gonna grab stuff.
I'll just loot.
What up?
Okay, alright.
I was gonna say something fucked up.
Alright.
If I...
Do I get a pass?
Someone said what up?
a poison water level.
Okay, guys, guys, guys, guys.
It's the...
When I read that, I was like, alright, Hitler.
I'm sorry.
I sound like, bro, like, what the fuck?
Why would you ever suggest that?
Water poison.
Guys, I think I've been playing too much deadlock.
I think I have to I'm playing too much deadlock, guys.
No,
I get it.
I...
All right.
Water, poison, and in the desert.
The best of three worlds.
All right, to cut down this fucking tree.
But I can't.
cut this out what the fuck what do i do
i guess oh my god i didn't see the fucking giant ass red
wall malice wall
sorry guys i was playing too much motors
it like increased my power power level i was already i was
toxic before without movas this is my final form one yoke on
one week of movas
all right here we go it's here the war has affected me
um oh there's the ladder i see it
Oh shit, a rift.
We should destroy the plant first.
Where the fuck is the plant?
Oh my god, it's infinite, isn't it?
If you're out, I get there.
I see it now.
I see it.
Oh my god, it is unlimited.
Dispatch.
Alright, there we go.
Okay.
We're gonna destroy that real quick.
That's it.
Alright.
Oh my god, why am I slashing?
There we go.
At least I'm farming the souls.
Well done.
Thank you, my wife.
I'm doing a good job, guys.
Jealous.
What the?
Okay.
That's right.
I can't look up too high.
All right, that should be all of them.
All right, suck.
Get in me.
Get inside me.
There we go.
That cleared the corruption.
splendid shall we proceed then um yeah i'm enjoying this
game a lot you shout out again to msi for sponsoring this
stream and letting me play more more onimusha i'll be giving
away some game codes at the end of the stream guys if you've
been enjoying watching this i want to check out the game
yourself i will be giving away five uh game codes at the end
of the stream but if you want to support this stream and
support oh my god where the fuck stuff that was over there
um do not fuck the plat um i need to figure out how to get
there where's my conveniently placed ladder it's over there
um you guys want to support this stream and support msi and
this channel please feel free to click on the link pinned in
the chat uh and in the description below um if you find msi
my You can get your own free copy of Onimusha.
And I always try to recommend their monitors.
I am using one of them right now.
That's how I get my insane carries.
Oh, that was a...
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that's him.
What happened to that lady?
I wonder.
Oh!
Don't even think about running away this to her.
Oh, my.
No, it's okay.
If he wants to run away, I'm fine with that.
The blood you're against, the wilder it gets.
I am okay if he wants to run.
If he wants to run away.
Into the blazer state.
Oh my.
Okay.
I just have to keep parrying until I get there.
Oh my god.
I would love to keep parrying if I...
Jesus Christ, this guy is scary.
Oh my god!
Oh, okay, I can't parry anymore.
I actually just have to dodge.
Okay.
Alright.
Jesus.
Oh my god.
He's so scared.
He's actually so scared.
Jesus.
His attack patterns are so weird.
Are you serious?
There we go.
Got one deflected.
Come on.
It'll take more than that.
Get your ass kicked.
That's right.
Woo!
What?
Getting my ass kicked!
They're like, oh yeah, but what?
Okay.
Once you're in the blazing stage, deflect their attack.
You will surely gain a significant advantage.
What?
Oh my god, I got confused what she was saying I'm stuck,
what?
Share that blazing energy into your blade.
Then you'll be able to press the attack.
Oh my god, I'm trapped.
My girlfriend got me distracted.
I was in the flow state.
Guys, I was in the bloat state.
You
heal, Mr. D'Ala temple.
Don't even think I'm running away this time.
Oh my god.
She fucked me up.
Classic Joki.
Blaming your...
I was so...
Blodding this thing up somehow makes it stronger.
You don't understand.
I was in the state.
Okay, it's fine.
I'm just gonna start slashing him.
Oh my god.
My wife can do no wrong.
Are you kidding me?
Okay.
Oh, come on.
I have to use dodges now.
All right, there you go Fuck
Okay That's good That's fine
There you go Trying to Okay, I got the dodges off I got the
dodges almost I almost got the dodges down I almost got it
down oh it's just my his damage like he's so tanky he's
really tanky
Don't even think about running away this time.
Here we go.
I got it.
The bloodier it gets, the wilder it gets.
I need to dodge that.
Nice!
Fuck!
No!
I can see your moves.
I'll keep deflecting them till you've got no stamina left.
Let's see how well you fight then.
Okay, it's fine.
It's no longer fine, guys.
It's no longer fine.
Can you get that?
No!
Are you serious?
I'm choking.
No!
Don't give them enough of you.
I'm trying!
I tell you!
Enter the blazing state and counter it.
I just have to keep parrying until I get there.
I was trying so...
We must heal quickly.
Oh my god, please!
You think I don't want to heal?
Okay.
All right, that's fine.
That's fine.
Oh, he's so hard.
He's actually so fast.
Oh, my God.
It feels like every boss fight is a final boss.
I, oh, my God.
Why?
Why are you backsealing me?
Why is my wife backsealing me?
You think I don't know I'm trying to heal?
You're that thing from humans that are tempting.
Don't even think about running away this time.
When he does that big hit, I should...
Okay.
Oh my god.
I need to remember the timing for this.
Fucking hell, you bitch!
Don't give them an opening.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Yeah, like, I'm definitely...
Okay,
just kill me.
I'm resetting.
I'm trying to do.
I swear to God, it's not intentional.
I hate that to cut this again too.
That's the worst part.
Don't get hit.
gives me the best advice just don't get it don't even think
about running away from that okay travel oh the blood you
were against the Waldron cats are you serious all right
And not dodge it!
Yeah, they're blazing energy into your blade.
Then you'll be able to press the attack.
Holy shit!
He's so hard.
Don't give them an opening.
Oh, he's so difficult.
I'm getting worse.
I'm actually getting worse.
Okay, reset, reset!
Reset!
My life...
I...
I'm this close.
Zizika, I'm this.
Zizika, I'm this close.
I'm this close.
I'm focusing.
Now I'm hard focusing.
I have to.
You're that thing from Kiyomi's Dera Temple.
Don't even think about running away this time.
Flooding this thing up somehow makes it stronger.
yeah are you serious I dodged it okay all right it's nice
are you fucking kidding me whore you whore oh my god he just
does charge attacks now
Here we go.
That was a parry!
That's it.
There we go.
Okay, it's fine, it's fine, that's fine.
Oh, that's fine.
I got the parry out though.
Are you kidding me?
That should not hit!
No, don't give them an opening.
What the heck?
You see that?
An angel dies!
And an angel loses his wing!
Yes, I hate us!
There has to be a way...
I'm sorry.
There has to be a...
I...
When she talked and then I lost my focus.
I'm sorry.
There has to be a way.
There has to be...
There...
I...
How do I...
I don't...
Please.
The thing
will kill me is that a temple.
Don't even think about running away this time.
The bloodier it gets, the Waldron gets.
Oh, my God.
There you go.
Oh, damn.
Are you serious?
That didn't hit?
Don't give them a no.
Oh, I swear to God.
I swear to God.
You tell me, I swear every time.
Every time she says that, I swear.
made for a table every time she talks that's my other creepy
i i'm trying to lock in right now i'm trying i'm trying so
hard to lock in and she's just backseeding me 20 miles from
the fight i
It's like...
I'm gonna put my...
It's not that I don't love her.
It's not that I don't love her, guys.
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh my god.
what yeah oh
my god I fucked up I fucked up a little bit yeah it's hard
because there's no sound cues now because I was using sound
cues too okay oh
my Okay.
Oh!
Are you serious?
No, no, no, no, no, no,
no.
Oh!
Oh, that was the closest.
It is harder.
It is harder, because I can't hear him, too.
It's, I can't hear him.
Oh, my God.
All right, I actually haven't fully locked in.
This guy's really difficult.
There we go.
All right.
Oh, my God!
Okay.
That's fine.
Like, this dodge I can do.
All right, there you go.
Oh, my God.
He fucking gave me a barrage.
He charged at me.
Oh wait, ah.
Okay.
It's fine.
Nice.
I can't get the timing for that.
Oh, when he does the downward smash!
Oh, the downward smash is hard.
I can't when she talks I lose focus I just love her so much
that her voice is just so beautiful that I lose focus I
guess I just you know her voice is just so beautiful
you know
oh maybe maybe if I change the language I won't know what
she's saying.
Wait, let me try that.
I'll just change the language.
Can I change it in here?
Okay.
Oh, I can't.
It won't let me change it in here.
I can't change.
I don't think I can.
I know it doesn't let me change it.
Her beautiful voice.
No.
Oh my all right, we'll try again Oh shit, don't give them an
opening I swear they got
Okay Okay, nice
I'm gonna try and parry more There we go
I should do a lot of damage now
Here we go
Once you're in the blazing stage, deflect their attack.
You will surely gain a significant advantage.
Here you go.
Is that all you've got?
All right, here you go.
Nice.
You don't need that head anywhere.
You don't.
There you go.
Don't get it.
Ah!
press why you bitch oh
my god okay are you serious yeah that's raising energy in
two i swear to god i swear to god i swear to god i swear to
god my beautiful wife i thought we had
okay okay
every time
don't give them an opening
I swear to God my beautiful lovely wife I'm not trying to I
really am not.
Oh, my beautiful.
I love you so much.
Oh, that's struggling.
I know.
I'm sorry.
My beautiful, handsome, sexy wife.
Drop it down and end this already.
One with the white back.
He's eating.
LFG.
It's disappearing.
That boss was fucking crazy.
Purifying the area.
We're safe now.
I would honestly just move.
Why the fuck would I stay here?
Or just move closer to the Onimusha.
okay cut down clear areas all right i'm surprised people are
even alive how are they alive everyone's come out of hiding
oh it seems like i mean there's still demons out they can go
about their lives again okay all right there's demons like
literally next to us but okay all that remains is kenyanji
temple the game are lurking there is sure to be formidable
Misashi, we should speak with Takamura before making our
next move.
The run here is cheap, Doki.
Where else would they...
That's so true.
Where else could they go?
You want to go back to Rokudo-chin-no-ji?
Indeed.
Oh my god, all right.
I do wish I can...
I wish I can abuse the...
I wish that this game had like the original Onimusha stuff
where you can abuse the different types of weapons.
what the fuck treasure reward what the fuck oh my god this
is a huge ass map I'm pretty sure I have to like go other
places whoa what new
bot no it's fine it's okay like there's literally a skull
area here area here why the fuck would I'm stay
I want to get the treasure.
Where is that?
It's like here?
Where do I get it?
It's like somewhere here.
Huh?
Cannot be destroyed from the side.
Oh, I have to go like here.
What the fuck is this treasure?
okay i could just go what's that all right what the fuck do
you mean i could go about my day
it's now safe guys do not worry we're so safe now like
i'm like i literally walked one block and then there's
demons very safe this is one block away much for you at all
what the fuck do they mean safe oh my god this guy out of
here I
hear them oh there he is
there you go all right so safe
it's like there's no way it's that easy
oh you'll just fuel for the gauntlets all right and then
let me suck this real quick all right let's do this let's do
this that's right boom boom boom that's right i've already
went through hell you're nothing compared to oh shit oh shit
i'm gonna go overconfidence the insidious killer it's a slow
killer i got a little bit too confident
it you never had a chance of beating me sorry everything's
five what am i supposed to get here i got there's tiger
lilies here uh maybe this way oh it must be treasure yeah i
might have too much confidence there all right only stone
that's good for upgrades I actually needed that for
upgrades.
Alright, and then this should... Oh, what?
Come on, back here.
Alright, we gotta go this way now.
I guess we could try going there and see what that gives me.
Let's say extra items.
Okay, but there's stuff here, too.
What's over here?
Loot?
Okay, it still does my marker stuff too.
Oh, there's a shrine here.
Alright.
Maybe I can upgrade.
I can.
Oh, thank God.
I actually need all of this.
Oh my God.
I've upgraded grades for days.
Maximum only power.
Okay, can I upgrade any of these?
Is it worth it?
Who's...
Fuck it, might as well.
Doesn't hurt.
Come here, you'll find me some treasure.
Oh, there is treasure.
Alright, knock, knock.
Aw, no one's here.
Owner is because of all the monsters around.
Oh, thank God for upgrades, though.
These are the people that thought it was safe.
because some bitch was like, guys, don't worry, we're safe
now.
We can go about our days.
And then they heard it.
Little did they know there was still lots of demons from
down the block.
Alright, that bridge is gone.
They said it was so safe.
Oh, God.
I went over there.
Oh, my God.
I really want to grab a lot of them.
these things.
Wait, what's up top?
They give me a ladder.
There has to be something there, right?
That's what ladders are for.
Right?
Ladder, ladder.
Oh my gosh, 4 a.m.
I'm so sorry, guys.
Oh, I fucking knew it.
Wish I could just shoot this guy.
No, I knew it.
I wish the arrows had more range.
I feel like I shouldn't have, like, an invisible wall.
you know
oh shit this is this guy let me what was he stonk wait
that's not fair he stunlocked me
I oh I'm so angry oh I'm so angry there's no way you are not
you are nothing no there's no way there's no way I am not
there's no way okay I am NOT dying to you I'm not dying I'll
Use every heal's possible.
I'm not dying to you.
Oh, fuck.
I won't kill you.
There's no way.
I will never die to you.
I refuse.
Well, here's something up top.
Did he reset?
Oh my god.
That made it easy.
Does he have a head?
He does.
Okay.
That's how it's done.
A masterful display.
Alright.
That's fine.
That was the last.
That was a boss fight.
Right there.
Why the fuck?
Oh, I thought that's a scarecrow.
Okay.
Like, what's that?
Oh, my God.
I felt like they were all people.
Alright.
Oh, I fucked up.
JK.
Dual wield.
I'm there.
Never fuck up.
Is there anything here?
I killed so many people.
I'm just worried.
Oh, there is stuff here.
Okay.
I'm going to heal just in case.
You made your miracle.
Gosh, so many.
How many items do I have?
Oh.
It's fine.
It'll be important later, right?
I'll make everything a shooter game eventually.
It's just easier, okay?
It's just...
It makes the game so much easier.
Helpful, true, it's just...
There's just nothing here.
I don't feel so safe, guys.
Oh, my God!
The backyard!
Okay, guys, guys, please stay back inside your homes.
I...
Guys, please go back.
inside your houses it is absolutely not safe the backyard is
all monsters your soul in the ghastly state you must rid
yourself these impurities without delays no that's just a
different postcode they're safe what's a mess very pushy for
a monk whatever I'll see what I can do Clear space, clear
mine.
What the fuck is this mission?
Head to a designated location?
Where?
Oh, this one?
I'm gonna just grab all these quests right now.
You're so ignorant, it's crazy.
If I saw them, pale lights are glowing in the night sky.
It was those moon folks, no doubt about it, like the old
town.
break as of the gemma as i said as i said as of the german
as if the gemma weren't enough to worry about i'll look into
it just don't go telling anyone else the last thing i need
is people panicking all right a lot of side quests i swear
to god if there's gemma back here all right okay at least
there's no gemma back here thank god yeah i think the moon
float that she's talking about might be demons all right uh
we're gonna head home and then we're gonna call it here i
realize i've been playing for six hours guys whoops because
we still have armor core to finish tomorrow
all right here we go i swear to god if i walk down this path
okay okay it's good there's real people there's real people
down there i was gonna say i swear to god if i walk down
this oh my god i fucking knew it every time
every turn around and then you're gonna get mugged that's
why you don't leave the pathway stupid if you didn't leave
you'd be alive
I stick to the path.
Where the fuck is the house?
Alright.
Let's see what we can upgrade.
I still only have one talisman.
Do I have enough to upgrade again?
No.
Alright, let's save here.
Alright.
Whoa.
That's fun.
I definitely might play.
We might have three streams of Onimusha next week.
Only because.
I think if I Not if I don't play this game For longer than
two days I'm gonna forget all the controls It's very
overwhelming My thoughts on this Very fun It's very very fun
I enjoyed it Oh my god I got a wave of tiredness just hit me
My eyes feel so heavy right now
The wave of tiredness Just fucking hate me Oh it hit me
right now The parry Oh my gosh, the parries are so
unforgiving.
It's like, I feel like it's easier.
The pair, it's, oh my gosh, it's so unforgiving, I feel
like.
Maybe I'm just not used to it.
I'm just not used to parrying.
It's just, I don't know.
It feels like the timing is crazy tight.
Like dodging is easy.
Dodging is easy.
Blocking and parrying, like the Issen, Issen and parrying is
very, like, yeah, the timing is very strict.
Oh, and everybody played Sekiro, so I don't know.
Anyway, guys, but we're not ending here.
I'm going to be giving out three.
Sorry, I can't even think of numbers.
Five codes, five free game codes.
Shout out to MSI for providing the game codes.
And for supporting the stream.
Like, again, guys, if you guys want to support the stream
and support MSI and this channel, please click on the link
pinned in my chat.
in the description it really does help a lot and they've
been great sponsors they've been really great good to me and
everything it always been super helpful with everything and
i've always loved working with them so please check out
their monitors um i used both of their mind i used uh i
think i have three of their monitors that i use for uh for
my streaming setup and i do have 500 hertz monitor it does
help improve my gameplay a lot um so yeah thank you again to
msi uh like i said please check out their monitors.
I highly recommend them for any of you are into gaming or
anything.
I really highly recommend their monitors, especially
competitive too, because it has improved my competitive
gaming.
Anyway, we're going to be doing giveaway.
I'm going to be, you're going to have one day, 24 hours, to
claim the game code.
When I pull out your name, let me...
Let's see.
Let me grab the night.
But when I pull out your name, please message my manager, DM
my manager on Twitter to clean your code.
This is my manager's Twitter.
I'll post it again after when we pull out all five people.
But yes, you have 24 hours to DM my manager.
If you get picked, and if, yes, it'll be on Twitter.
It'll be on Twitter.
And please make sure to provide evidence that this is your
YouTube account that got picked for the giveaway.
All right, let me pull up the Nightbot right now.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, oh, I pressed too hard.
all right to enter please make sure to do okay let me type
it on the stream uh all right you wish to enter ow i'm like
post oh no i'm so tired now it's like post onimusha i'm
gonna add my fingers my thumbs hurt i've been pressing my
thumbs hurt so much what kids what do i do i know let me cut
off my fingers so the pain will be gotten i have an idea
exclamation point enter to enter the giveaway if you get
picked you have 24 hours to claim the code please dm at um
what's your twitter handle inspired silent you would you not
win a game cube
with proof that you are you all right here you go all right
you guys ready there's no game guys no game cube is just
it's just the code all right i'm gonna do a countdown for
the first winner all right guys remember the exclamation
point enter guys just the game code not any oh my gosh i
have to walk dad after this i'm so tired i'm so tired to
walk dad after this oh my god i'm so fucking hell i didn't
realize how long i've been playing for all right
congratulations kent congratulations the first winner of the
onimusha giveaway remember to dm inspire silent on twitter
with proof that you are you and you have 24 hours to claim
it um if you don't claim it the code will just uh
or staff I don't know it really depends if there's codes
available congratulations kit kit are you here I didn't know
if you're here to claim it kit I can see your messages if
you say anything in chat oh he okay all right kits here kids
here remember to claim your code all right second second
winner get ready
two four oh wait we already we don't reroll winner alright
but sorry I'm very my brain is very scrambled right now
today's been a day today's been a very long day guys it has
it has been a very long day for me today everything happened
today uh everything and anything that could happen happened
today um all right five four three two
OMR, congratulations!
Congratulations on winning a game code!
Congrats!
Make sure to type in chat so I know you're here.
Alright, remember the DM, inspire silent Twitter to claim
it, and also give proof that you are you.
Whether or not it's your YouTube channel, just making sure
that you're linked, you know, we don't want to give it to a
random person.
That was just, I'm OMR, like, yeah.
all right three left guys three left we're gonna we might do
a little lightning round here in five four three two one how
half congratulations half congratulations I'm winning an
Onimusha game code are you here are you here I don't see any
messages you're like exclamation point enter I'm bye he's
like who am i kidding why did i even enter this giveaway
it's not gonna be me but it is you we need to know if you're
here or we have to re-roll half half you did it half where
are you give us enter and leave oh okay half is here half is
here he's like i hear someone saying my name Is it me?
Did I do?
Alright, congratulations.
Like I said, remember to DM Inspired Silent on Twitter.
Guys, I will post a link to the Twitter account.
Actually, I can do that now for you guys.
Oh my God, I'm actually so I felt like I used everything
I've had.
Oh, I feel, okay.
These boss, I'm...
They are... Okay, I feel like I haven't struggled Because
it's like, you can't dodge forever too, that's the thing.
I can't use dodge forever because you'd barely do any damage
if you don't parry.
That's the hardest part.
You have to parry or you do no damage.
You do like p-shooter damage.
And that's like the worst part.
So I can't just abuse dodging forever because I have to
parry just so I can.
I don't extend the fight to 80 years.
Like, I feel like this game is harder than any Souls-like
game I play.
Like, it's harder than Wukon.
Like, I can't cheese it, too.
There's no actual cheesing.
Like, I would, in Wukon, I would cheese all the, I would
combo, like, different abilities.
And in, like, Bloodborne, I, oh, my God.
In Bloodborne, it's like, no, you don't have to enter every
role.
Every, every time, if you enter already, don't worry, you're
just, you're in the, you don't have to enter every role
again.
Wait, am I on three or four?
Oh, my gosh, I'm so tired.
I said, it took a lot of mental power.
It took a lot of my mental capacity to play this game.
But I'm having fun.
I'm having a lot of fun.
It's just, I think this is the hardest Souls-like game I've
ever played.
It's definitely the hardest Souls-like game.
To me, it's harder than Bloodborne, and it's harder than...
What else did I play?
It's harder than Bloodborne.
It's harder than Elden Ring, honestly.
I feel like I'm bashing my head against the wall so I don't
know it's just a pairing it's literally just a pairing yeah
I personally think for me it's hard an Elden Ring and and
Bloodborne
okay all right next winner in uh five four three two one Azu
Congratulations Azu We're being the fourth giveaway winner I
think also like They give you a filter boss in the beginning
too There's a filter They're like we saw you brute forcing
all your fights Now it's time to play a real game Yeah We
saw your X combos.
Would be a shame if we do a little mix-up.
Azu, congratulations, Azu.
Remember to DM and SpireSilent on Twitter to claim your
code.
You have 24 hours.
Yes, it's you.
Yes, you.
You won.
Azu, it is.
is you who else could it be all right these is all steam
codes by the way this is all on steam it's on console it's
on steam all right this is the last one everyone last one
last giveaway winner all right you guys all ready all right
the last one the final countdown
Three, two, one.
Boop.
Suki!
Congratulations on being the final winner.
The final, oh my gosh, the final, I'm sorry, another wave
hit me.
I got it.
I'm sorry, another wave just fucking, fucking bulldozed me
just now.
But congratulations on being the last winner for the
giveaway.
I hope you guys all enjoy Onimusha in your own time and also
suffer like me.
I hope you all suffer.
But as always, before we go, you shout out to MSI for
providing all these game codes, providing me a game code,
for supporting the stream, for sponsoring the stream, and
for, you know, being there, always supporting this channel
and everything.
I really do appreciate MSI for being a homie.
Shout out to Andy for getting the director to give me a
shout out.
I did not expect that at all.
Like, oh, oh, wait.
Oh, I'll put it down.
tomorrow i don't
the onimusha package i was like i don't think i have the
strength to even open the package guys i don't even guys i
don't think i'm strong enough to even open the box shout out
to andy um the uh the community manager for capcom usa for
getting the shout out I did not expect that at all oh yeah
in spot uh let me set link the that's actually crazy I I
didn't even I I thought you guys were like I thought you
guys were just telling me the game that has a message or
something I didn't realize I didn't realize it was like the
actual like fucking the director of Onimusha was fucking
making it I oh my god
I was just like what Andy I knew it was him I knew it
because I was telling him like my history of Onimusha and
like I knew it was him I that did it uh but thank you again
shout out to everyone yeah shout out to you guys oh my god
it has like a 10 and 9 it has a high rating on review sites
right now.
Yeah, but check out.
Here's Andy's Twitter.
Give him some love, guys.
He's done a lot for me.
I just met, I met him at Capcom Cup in Japan.
And this guy's been clutch.
He was there with me in Alcatraz.
We broke out of Alcatraz to get there.
And then he all he got after breaking out of Alcatraz all he
got was a be gay do crime bracelet Like and the muscle mommy
bar.
Yeah, he was there with me at the muscle mommy bar
No, he beat my ass in street fighter guys he fucking beat my
he was playing JP guys.
Yeah, he's a JP player him i forgive him for being a jp
player
anyway um as always everybody say hi jr to posh check get up
and move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up
for me head to bed because you deserve his really late right
now guys so um please make sure to get a good night's rest
uh but also remember to check out like i said before we go
check out all check out the links guys pinned in my chat
remember to click on those Here, I'll spam it too.
And we're going to check it out and support the stream.
Bye, guys.
I'll see you guys later, everyone.
Thank you.
I'm sorry for being in the late.
Like I said, everything was going happening.
But I really do appreciate all the support.
Bye-bye, everybody.
Bye-bye.